FISCAL REVIEW WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
THOSE SENATORS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY COULD YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES NOW.
WINDOWS ONE SECOND CAN WE HAVE
IT ON THE SCREEN GO AHEAD
SENATOR MELINDA'S. GO AHEAD
SENATOR IS HERE AND YOU HAVE
SUPPORT STAFF WITH YOU. SURE
YEAH IN THE OTHER ROOM GOOD CAN
YOU IDENTIFY THEM. CASEY
DELIVERS EXCELLENT THANKS SO
MUCH. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LA- FOR PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR A REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MEET YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS. FIVE BECAUSE WE NEED
TO ELIMINATE THAT ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK AND EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU TURN THE
PROGRAM- PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN TO SPEAK. R.
I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HEARING ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE HEARING FROM ANY PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THOSE REMOTE HEARING
ROOMS PLUS A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO TESTIFY TODAY. THREE
FOR THOSE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. AND THIS IS THE NUMBER
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NARROW.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
EIGHT SIX ONE ZERO ONE EIGHT
FIVE. AND TO SEE HOW THE CALLER
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
LOOK AT THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID THAT
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIV MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE MATTER IS
CUSTOMARY. THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
AND SUCH MAY CREATE SOME LAG
TIMES PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. SO BEFORE
WE BEGIN LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MISS WIN COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
SCANNER HERE SCANNER HERE
SENATOR NELSON. COPYRIGHT.
CORTESE DAISY HERE DOLLY.
TORONTO TORONTO HERE AIKMAN A
MAN HERE GROSS. GROVE HERE
LAYERED LAYERED HERE WHERE.
MELINDA'S. LENDERS HERE- B. AS
SOON MAN. MAN HERE NEWMAN NO
MAN HERE- TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE
HERE CAN. CAN HEAR ROCK. ROTH
HERE STERN. BY KATHY. HAVE WE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM WE HAVE A
FARM THANK YOU SO WE NOTE A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
AND FOR ARGENTA TODAY WE HAVE
ONE BILL. AND THAT IS THE BILL
ON THE- SCHOOL RE OPENING. AND
JUST AS A FEW COMMENTS BEFORE
WE BEGIN. SO AS ALL OF US
PAINFULLY NO THE PANDEMIC.
BEGAN IN TERMS OF OUR FULL
COGNIZANCE OF IT ABOUT A YEAR
AGO. AND AS A RESULT TO PROTECT
ALL OF OUR HEALTH MANY OF OUR
DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS INCLUDING
SCHOOLS AND MUCH OTHER ACTIVITY
WAS SHUT DOWN. AND THAT
PANDEMIC THE PANDEMIC WE ARE IN
HAS DISRUPTED K. TWELVE
EDUCATION ACROSS THE STATE AS
WELL AS COLLEGE AND ALL
EDUCATION IN EVERY ACTIVITY WE
HAVE. BUT IN TERMS OF SCHOOLS
FOR STUDENTS AND SCHOOL STAFF
TO ADAPT. TO A- ONLINE OR
DISTANCE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
THEN WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
REPRESENT AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE ASSEMBLY THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO PROVIDE A
PATH FOR RE OPENING SCHOOLS AND
GETTING OUR CHILDREN BACK IN
THE CLASSROOM. WHILE
EMPHASIZING OR SECURING AND
INSISTING ON FIFTY MEASURES
THAT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS AND THE STAFF BUT ALSO
THEIR FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITY.
STAY SAFE AND WE CAN MINIMIZE
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS. IT
RESPECTS THE DIFFERING LOCAL
CIRCUMSTANCES ACROSS THE STATE
BY PROVIDING KEEP FLEXIBILITY
BUT IT ALSO RESPECTS THE VIRUS
BY ALSO REQUIRING CERTAIN
SAFETY PROTOCOLS. THE PACKAGE
PROVIDES SIX POINT SIX BILLION
IN ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COVER THE
COSTS OF RE OPENING SAFELY.
WOULD OF COURSE OBVIOUSLY
INCLUDE. THAT TESTING-
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT- THE WHOLE
VARIETY OF THINGS AS WE KNOW
THAT INDOOR ENVIRONMENTS NEED
TO BE SAFE. AND TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION AND
SUPPORTS THAT WILL BE NEEDED AS
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS
RECOVER FROM THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT
THAT WE ARE CONSIDERING- THAT
SIX POINT SIX BILLION TO
BILLION IS PROVIDED. FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION GRANTS TO
SUPPORT THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT OPEN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AND TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL
ACCORDING TO THE TIER OF THE
COUNTY THAT THE DISTRICT IS
LOCATED IN. TO ACCESS THIS
MONEY. OR TO EAT YOU KNOW FULLY
UTILIZE THE MONEY THAT WE ARE
AUTHORIZING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MUST OPEN BY APRIL FIRST OR
THEY WILL LOSE A PORTION OF IT.
IF THE DISTRICT IS NOT OPEN BY
MAY FIFTEENTH THEY WILL LOSE
THEIR ENTIRE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANT NOW THAT SAID
WITHIN THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH
THE HIGHEST SPREAD OF COVE IT
THE HIGHEST RISK. THE AMOUNT OF
OPENING IS MINIMAL COMPARED TO
THOSE COUNTIES WITH THE LOWER
RATES OF RISK. NOTHING IN THE
BILL REQUIRES A SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO SLOW DOWN THEIR REOPENING
PLANS INDICATES THAT THEY MAY
HAVE ALREADY OPENED OR IN THE
CASE WHERE THEY MAY BE OPENING
EARLIER FROM THE DATES LISTED
IN THIS BILL. THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION IN THE- LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES GRANTS WHICH ARE
PROVIDED TO ALL DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE EXPANDED LEARNING TIME
AND ACADEMIC INTERVENTIONS
THROUGH FOR EXAMPLE BUT NOT
LIMITED TO SUMMER SCHOOL.
EXTENDED YEAR EXTENDED
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME ONE ON ONE
TUTORING OR WHATEVER THE
DISTRICT FEELS IS MOST NEEDED
TO HELP THEIR STUDENTS WITH
LEARNING LOSS. SCHOOLS THAT
WERE UNABLE TO OPEN IN TIME TO
RECEIVE AN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANT MAY USE 10%
OF THEIR FUNDS TO COVER THE
COST OF RE OPENING. AND IN
ADDITION 10% IS SET ASIDE FOR
HIRING. EDUCATORS WHO ARE
ESSENTIAL TO PROVIDING
INDIVIDUALIZED STUDENT SERVICES
PARTICULARLY FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND ENGLISH
LEARNERS. D. R. OPENING ALSO
REQUIRES ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO HAVE CODE NINETEEN SCHOOL
SAFETY PLANS- AND THOSE THAT
ARE OPERATING IN A PURPLE TEAR
MEANING THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE THE HIGHEST RISK OF
COVERT STILL IS ONGOING. MUST
ADHERE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH'S ASYMPTOMATIC
KOBE TESTING CADENCE GUIDANCE
HOWEVER THIS GUIDANCE IS
FLEXIBLE FOR THOSE DISTRICTS IN
THE LESS RISKY TEARS- THE
AGREEMENT CODIFIES THE
GOVERNOR'S ANNOUNCEMENT THE
BEGINNING MARCH FIRST SCHOOL
STAFF BEGINNING MARCH FIRST SO
YESTERDAY SCHOOL STAFF AND FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS MUST BE
EQUALLY PRIORITISED FOR
VACCINES STATE WIDE. AND
ADDITIONALLY 10% OF THE STATE'S
VACCINE SUPPLY WILL BE OFFERED
TO K. TWELVE EDUCATORS AND
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. AND I
THINK THIS IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT. CARE
TEACHERS STAFF AND PARENTS TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE GETTING BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM AND
VACCINATIONS ARE ONE OF THE KEY
WAYS TO DO IT THE BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE VACCINATION AS A
PRECONDITION FOR SCHOOLS TO
OPEN BUT IT DEFINITELY GIVES A
PATHWAY FOR EDUCATORS AND STAFF
TO GET VACCINATIONS. AN
pPROVIDED FOR SUPPORTING AND
ENSURING SAFE SCHOOL OPERATIONS
SAFETY ENFORCEMENT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
ACHIEVING POSITIVE STUDENT
OUTCOMES. AND THEN. THERE'S
SOME TECHNICAL CHANGES BUT I
WOULD ALSO JUST OUTSIDE THE BY
MAKING TEMPORARY CHANGES IN THE
GPA REQUIREMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENT FINANCIALAID. THIS
BILL PREVENTS STUDENTS WHO ARE
UNABLE TO EXCEL AND DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND YOU MAY HAVE THEN
EXPERIENCED A LOW GRADE POINT
AVERAGE DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
FROM FACING DIFFICULT TIMES
THAT LIMIT THEIR FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES. SO WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND PRESENTING THE BILL. IN LA-
MAY HAVE SOME COMMENT OR MAY
JUST BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER HEARING HE BILL IT IS
THE ONLY BILL ON THE AGENDA.
AND THEN WE WILL VOTE AFTER THE
PUBLIC COMMENT- MISTER NIELSEN
VICE CHAIR DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENT BEFORE WE HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO. ALL
RIGHT FINE LET'S GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING CHECK SCANNER VICE
CHAIR NELSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ERICA LEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT THE SCHOOL
RE OPENING EARLY ACTION TRAILER
BILL. WHICH HAS SHEER SKINNER
STATED IS A CULMINATION OF
SEVERAL WEEKS OF. INTENSE
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY- THESE
CONVERSATIONS REALLY JUMP
STARTED THE SCHOOL RE OPENING
DISCUSSION SHIFTING THE
DISCUSSION TO WHETHER SCHOOLS
WILL RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION TO WHEN AND HOW
SCHOOLS WERE RETURNED- WILL RE
OPEN ANY SEPARATIST REALLY
DEMONSTRATE THE HIGH PRIORITY
THAT EACH PARTY HAS PLACED ON
RETURNING STUDENTS. EDUCATORS
AND STAFF SAFELY BACK TO SCHOOL.
EIGHTY SIX APPROPRIATE SIX
POINT SIX MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FIND TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES- INCLUDING
TWO BILLION FOR IN PERSON
GRANTS IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
GRANTS AND FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION FOR EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. THE TWO BILLION
AND PERSON INSTRUCTION GRANTS
WILL BE ALLOCATED TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES BASED ON
AN EQUITY- FORMULA. LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND
SCHOOLS THAT ARE IN RECEIPT OF
THESE BRANDS MUST OFFER
CONTINUOUS AND PERSON
INSTRUCTION BEGINNING APRIL ONE.
DISTRICTS MAY BEGIN PROVIDING
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AS LATE
AS MAY FIFTEENTH HOWEVER THEIR
GRANT ALLOCATIONS WILL WILL BE
REDUCED BY 1% FOR EACH DAY OF
INSTRUCTION THAT IN PERSON
LEARNING IS NOT OFFERED. BUT IT
CAN BE USED FOR ANY PURPOSE
CONSISTENT WITH PROVIDING IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION WHICH MAY
INCLUDE PP TESTING CLEANING
VENTILATION- SITE UPGRADES
ALLERGIES. AND SOCIAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS FOR
STUDENTS. THAT'S COOL ALL
SCHOOLS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
TIER ASSIGNMENT THEY'RE COMING
TO YOUR TIME IT WILL BE
REQUIRED TO OFFER OPTIONAL IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO ALL
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEN COHORTS OF STUDENTS AND
PRIORITIZE GROUPS AND THE
PRIORITIZED GROUPS INCLUDE-
PEOPLE THAT RISK- ABUSE NEGLECT.
BALLS THAT ARE HOMELESS PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN FOSTER CARE-
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
STUDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS
STUDENTS WHO HAVEN'T BEEN
ENGAGED DURING DISTANCE
LEARNING. ONCE A SCHOOL IS
ELIGIBLE HOWEVER UNDER PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE THEY MUST ALSO
OFFER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION TO
AT LEAST ALL STUDENTS IN
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH THE SECOND GRADE. AND-ONCE THEY'RE IN THE RED ORANGE
OR YELLOW TIER IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION MUST BE OFFERED TO
AT LEAST ALL ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS- CATER SIX. OUT
STUDENTS IN THE PRIORITIZED
GROUPS AND AT LEAST ONE FULL
GRADE IN THE SEVENTH THROUGH
TWELFTH GRADE TO SPAM. THE FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION IS FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITY
FRANCE. BEGIN THE CRITICAL WORK
OF ADDRESSING THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
WILL BE ALLOCATED TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. AGAIN
BASED ON THE EQUITY BASED LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA- AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
WILL BE PROVIDED FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE HOMELESS. THE FUNDS
WILL BE SUPPLEMENTAL- WILL BE
FOR SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION
AND SUPPORT. OF OUR SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF
STUDENTS SOMETHING VITALLY
IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS AT THIS
TIME. THE USE OF THESE FUNDS
MAYBE FOR SUMMER SCHOOL LONGER
DAYS THAT'S PROVIDING MORE
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME AS WELL AS
ACCELERATING PROGRESS TO CLOSE
LEARNING GAPS- HEARING AS AN
EXAMPLE LEARNING RECOVERY
PROGRAMS COMMUNITY LEARNING
HOGS- AGAIN SUPPORTS FOR-
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. IN
ADDITION EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX ALSO
CODIFIES GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
MAN ON VACCINES FOR EDUCATION
SECTOR WORKERS WERE BY 10% A
FIRST DOSE IS A VACCINE. WILL
BE AVAILABLE. IT OPERATES YOU
EDUCATION SECTOR STAFF THIS
INCLUDES TEACHERS CLASSIFIED
WORKERS ADMINISTRATORS- AND
SCHOOL STAFF SAID AFRICA IS
ALREADY UNDER WAY STARTED
YESTERDAY AS- THAT YOU'RE
MENTIONED AND WILL GO A LONG
WAY TO GET THE STATE'S
EDUCATION FACTOR IN- INCLUDING
THAT THE POPULATIONS I JUST
MENTIONED TO VACCINATED QUICKLY.
MAYBE EIGHTY SIX ALSO CONTAINS
ADDITIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
MEASURES INCLUDING REQUIRING
ANY PUBLIC OR PRIVATE SCHOOL TO
NOTIFY THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER NO LATER THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AFTER LEARNING O A
POSITIVE CASE. ON A SCHOOL SITE.
IT ALSO DOUBLES AS A SYSTEM
THAT WILL PROVIDE A SAFETY
REVIEW BY THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. WHEN ANY
SCHOOL HAS TWO OR MORE
OUTBREAKS OF KOBE NINETEEN. IT
ALSO OPERATES TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TO THE STATES FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND ENFORCEMENT OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
THIS IS A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF THE BELL ON THE STATE'S
SCHOOL REOPENING PLANS MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA HOLMES AND I
ARE AVAILABLE TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MEMBERS I HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M. I
DON'T KNOW IF THE LA- WANTED TO
MAKE A COMMENT OR WHETHER THEY
WANT TO JUST RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS. MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
GABE PRODUCT- FROM THE LA- AND-
WE DID NOT PREPARE- COMMENT IN
ADVANCE BUT WE ARE HERE- AND
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT LET ME SEE
IF THERE ARE MEMBER- QUESTIONS.
STIR IN MY UP SENATOR NELSON.
TO FINANCE HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY
THAT THIS IS OPENING SCHOOLS
WHEN IT COULD BE BUT FOR ONLY
ONE SINGLE DAY. IN CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION HOW DID THEY
QUALIFY TO THE FULL TIME
STUDENTS IF THEY'RE ONLY IN THE
CLASSROOM ONE SINGLE DAY IT'S
STILL REMOTE LEARNING IS IT NOT.
THE PART THAT I NEED SENATOR
NELSON NELSON THISIS ERIC LEE
I THINK YOUR- RESPONDING TO A
HYBRID INSTRUCTION IS THAT
CORRECT. THE CERTAIN CERTAIN
FOUNDATION IN THE CLASSROOM AND
SOMEDAY PERHAPS THROUGH
DISTANCE LEARNING. SIXTY LET ME
ASK THE GRANTS WOULD- ALLOW.
LOCAL DECISION MAKING IN TERMS
OF- HOW STUDENTS COME BACK TO
SCHOOL AND IN REGARDS TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION SO IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THERE COULD BE A
HYBRID APPROACH WHERE. STUDENTS
ARE IN THE CLASSROOM FOR
CERTAIN DAYS OF THE WEEK AND
OUR DISTANCE LEARNING IN OTHER
DAYS BUT B. AND B. AT INTENT IS
TO GET AS MANY- SCHOOLS REOPEN
AS POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT- THE TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS NEED AND SOME OF THAT
MAY JUST. REALLY DEPEND ON HOW
THE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
ALLEYS TO FIND- HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THAT. IS THIS NOT
CONTINUING A- HISTORIC TREND IN
CALIFORNIA K. TWELVE EDUCATION
OF DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
CHARTER SCHOOLS. I'M I'M GONNA
TRY THAT QUESTION TO MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA HOLMES IN
REGARDS TO CHARTER SCHOOLS
THANK YOU. YES THE HOME
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SO
THAT THE I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IS AND THE FACT
THAT OF THE TWO PROPOSALS THE
TWO BILLION PROPOSAL ON THE
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
PROPOSAL. AND NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL ARE NOT
INCLUDED AND AS BEING ELIGIBLE
FOR THE TWO BILLION IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANT YES AND WHAT
THAT IS A REFLECTION OF. HIS
DEATH THANK YOU WITH THAT IN
THE REFLECTION OF THE FACT
THAT- FOR FAMILIES WHO CHOOSE
TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL.
THEY DO SO- WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT- MUCH IF NOT
ALL AND DEPENDING O THE
PROGRAM AS THAT- EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM WILL BE PROVIDED I'M IN
A DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL SO
THERE'S NOT AS MUCH- CONCERNED
ABOUT BRINGING KIDS BACK INTO
THE CLASSROOM BECAUSE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE CHOSEN
THAT THE DISTANCE DURING PEAK
SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE CHOSEN.
HOWEVER I WOULD NOTE THAT ALL
OTHER CHARTER SCHOOL CLASSMATES
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE TWO BILLION IN FUNDING
AND ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS
INCLUDING ON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION.
AND IN THE EXTENDED LEARNING
TIME AND- ACADEMIC
OPPORTUNITIES GRANT SO- THERE'S
ENOUGH YOU CAN FIND THE
VALUABLE. AND FOR ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE BOTH GREAT. THANK
CHAIR MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO HIM
ASK BOTH QUESTIONS THAT I WAS
SEEKING THE ANSWERS AND
RESPONSES TO I DO HAVE A
CONCERN- ABOUT ONE SECOND
CENTER GROVE YOU'RE MIKE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ON. LET'S
SEE IS THAT BETTER YES THAT'S
BETTER HY HOLD THAT POLICY
STARTED THAT'S OKAY MA'AM MY AT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY I'M
CALLING FROM T. HE MET- ASK THE
QUESTIONS THAT I WAS- SEEKING
ANSWERS AND RESPONSES TO. ABOUT
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND ABOUT THE
DISTANCE LEARNING ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE ON THE HYBRID PROGRAM. I
DO HAVE A CONCERN THAT THIS
BILL HAS A LARGE FOCUS ON THE
HYBRID PROGRAM WHERE. THE MONEY
WOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES EVEN IF THEY JUST
OPENED UP ONE DAY A WEEK. I
DON'T THINK THAT- OPENING ONE
DAY A WEEK IS WHAT OUR PARENTS
ARE LOOKING FOR. IN THE
EDUCATION OF OUR CHILDREN- AND
I THINK THAT- THERE SHOULD BE
SOME TYPE OF ADDITION TO THIS
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES THE
SCHOOLS TO OPEN. IN A
CONSISTENT MANNER SO THAT
PARENTS CAN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY HAVE THEIR CHILDREN
EDUCATED. IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM A LOT OF THE PEOPLE IN
MY COMMUNITY. CANNOT US AFFORD
TO PUT THEIR CHILDREN IN AN
EXPENSIVE PRIVATE SCHOOLS-
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PAY FOR PRIVATE SCHOOL
EDUCATION THEIR CHILDREN HAVE
NOT MISS THIS ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY THIS ONE YEAR GAP
IN- IN EDUCATION ACHIEVEMENT.
AND THEY HAVE NOT BEEN AND
EXCLUDED FROM IN PERSON
LEARNING. AND THAT'S NOT THE
CASE IN MY DISTRICT I HAVE A
LOT OF INDIVIDUALS ON THE
MAJORITY OF THE INDIVIDUAL'S
NEEDS PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO BE
OPEN. AND I THINK- ALTHOUGH
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
INCENTIVIZE SCHOOLS. MY CONCERN
IS THAT- THE SCHOOLS WILL ONLY
OPEN ONE DAY A WEEK AND THAT
STILL PRESENT PRESENTS A MAJOR
PROBLEM IN EDUCATION FOR THE
MAJORITY. OF OUR STUDENTS IN
THIS STATE. I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THAT- IS THERE TO BE ANY
DISCUSSION OR MOVING FORWARD IN
NEGOTIATIONS ON THE HYBRID
LEARNING PROGRAM. HI SENATOR
ERICA LEE AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
THINK THE ONE THING- YOU KNOW
THERE'S THIS FRAMEWORK PROVIDES
IS A LOT OF LCAL DISCRETION
AND AGAIN THIS IS NOT A MANDATE
BUT FOR THOSE DISTRICTS THAT
ARE- IN RECEIPT OF FINES. THERE
NEEDS TO BE A PLAN FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AND AGAIN
THE STATE DOESN'T DICTATE WHAT
THAT PLAN SHOULD LOOK LIKE- AND
IT IS REALLY UP TO BE
ADMINISTRATORS TEACHERS
PARENTS- IN IN THOSE LOCAL.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DECIDE WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE FOR THEM WITH
THE BEST MODEL IS FOR THEM.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DRAWS YOU IN
AND SENATOR MELINDA'S. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I SUPPORT THIS
THE AGREEMENT OR THIS
UNDERSTANDING HERE- I BELIEVE
VERY STRONGLY THAT EDUCATION
STAFF. NEED TO BE PROTECTED AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND THAT THE
STUDENTS- AND A MOTHER YOU KNOW
ALL THE SCHOOL STAFF THAT NEED
TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK QUICKLY
AND SAFELY AND I KNOW THAT'S
BEEN THE DIFFICULT BALANCE HERE
BUT WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE BOTH-
IN LOS ANGELES VALLEY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
CHILDREN- HAVE WORKING PARENTS
AWAY FROM HOME. AND SO- THEY'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH ISSUES OF-
WANTING TO GO TO SCHOOL A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER DON'T HAVE
CONNECTIVITY DIDN'T HAVE
CONNECTIVITY OF THE DEVICES OF-
A LOT WAS DONE BY RALLY IS USD
TO MAKE UP FOR THAT- BUT I HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS OUT OF
CONCERN FOR. THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE THOSE CHILDREN LIVE
HAVE A VERY VERY HIGH NUMBER OF
CASES AND DEATHS ARE VERY
DISPROPORTIONATELY- ANSWER TO
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT IS WHAT IS
THE IMPACT OF THE CHILDREN THAT
LIVE- IN THE PURPLE TIER SUCH
AS- LA COUNTY WHAT IS THE
IMPACT OF THIS- A PROPOSAL TO
THEM- AND SECOND IS HOW DOES
THIS PROPOSAL ADDRESS THE
LEARNING LOSS THAT THESE OUR
CHILDREN HAVE. GONE THROUGH
THANK YOU MANAGER. HI ALL
START- IN RESPONSE TO THAT
QUESTION- CALLING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THEN
I'LL TURN IT OVER FOR SOME MORE
DETAILS TO MY COLLEAGUE JESSICA
HOLMES. I'M IN REGARDS TO LA
COUNTY IN ANY COUNTY THAT IS IN
THE PURPLE TEAR- DEPENDING ON
CASE RATES- SCHOOLS- THAT ARE
IN RECEIPT OF THESE FUNDS WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO- PROVIDE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO ALL
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AS
WELL AS AS COHORTS- OF
STUDENTS- IN THE PRIORITIZED
POPULATIONS THAT I MENTIONED
BEFORE SUCH AS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS- STUDENTS THAT ARE
HOMELESS STUDENTS IN FOSTER
CARE CENTER- AND SO. THOSE
SCHOOLS IN PURPLE TEARS HAVE
THE- THEY THEY MUST PROVIDE. IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO AT LEAST
THOSE GROUPS AND MANY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS I THINK ARE THE
ONES THAT YOU'VE MENTIONED
CENTER SENATOR- IN REGARDS TO-
CASE RATES AS CASE RATES GO
DOWN. SCHOOLS MUST OFFER- IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION THROUGH THAT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH SECOND GRADE- AND SO
AGAIN THOSE ARE THOSE ARE CASE
RATES- BETWEEN SEVEN AND TWENTY
FIVE AND ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND-
IN TERMS OF THE- LEARNING LIVES
THROUGH WE HAVE THE FOUR POINT
SIX BILLION AND I WANT TO JUST
POINT OUT THAT IN BOTH CASES
THE TWO BILLION AND THE FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION WOULD BE
ALLOCATED BASED ON- THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA WHICH
IS- OBVIOUSLY- HEAVILY-
FORMULATED SO THAT- IT BENEFITS
THE LOWEST INCOME- ELEAZAR. AND
SO AGAIN YOU HAVE- THAT
POPULATION I THINK IS- THE ONE
THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IN
REGARDS TO LA. BUT JUST IN
TERMS OF THE DISTRIBUTION IT
IS- BASED ON- IT'S AN EQUITY
BASED DISTRIBUTION BASED ON LC
ABOUT FORMULA. AND THOSE FUNDS
WOULD BE ALLOCATED BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN THOSE
AREAS THAT ARE LOW INCOME- AND
I DON'T KNOW IF I JESSICA IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING
TO THAT. THE FIRM. THE I. T.
SHE'S TURNING ANSWERED WHEN I
HEARD BACK OKAY GREAT YOUR MUTE
CAN YOU GO AHEAD YES PLEASE
PROCEED YEAH I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT I WAS ON MUTE AND DEAF
HOME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
SENATOR OUT THAT YOU BRING UP
AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE AND WE
HAVE HEARD SIGNIFICANT AND
FEEDBACK FROM FAMILY ABOUT THAT
AND THERE IS THERE IS A TENSION
BETWEEN WANTING THAT MAKE SURE
THE KIDS ARE BACK IN SCHOOL BUT
ALSO A LOT OF CONCERN
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN SEVERELY HARD HIT BY
CODY NINETEEN- THAT YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEND THEIR
KIDS BACK- IF. THERE'S A RISK
OF INFECTION. AND SO I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT WHAT ARE
PROPOSAL. THAT REALLY TRIED TO
BALANCE- BOTH THE CONCERN OF
HIM LEADS AND TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO FEEL SAFE AND
GETTING THEIR KIDS BACK. BUT
ALSO PROVIDING THEM WITH
OPTIONS BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT DURING A TIME LIKE
THIS. SO WHILE THE TWO BILLION
REQUIRES AT LEAST OFFER- IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE FAMILIES TO ACCEPT THAT
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. IF THEY
FEEL LIKE THE DISTANCE LEARNING
MODEL IS A BETTER FIT FOR THEN-
IN ADDITION TO FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION ALLOW UP TO. 15% OF
THOSE FUNDS TO BE USED TO
SUPPORT AND ENHANCE DISTANCE
LEARNING. THAT BOTH BOTH YOU
NEED TO CHOOSE TO STAY IN THE
DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL CAN
ALSO RECEIVE. AN IMPROVED
SERVICE HOLD SO THAT THE OTHER
TWO I THINK VERY IMPORTANT
POINTS THERE I THINK- IT
FINALLY I THINK ONE OF THE
REALLY IMPORTANT THINGS ABOUT
THE FOUR POINT SIX MILLION. IS
THAT THERE'S A REAL FOCUS ON
EXPANDING LEARNING TIME WE
RECOGNIZE THAT. STUDENTS MAY
NOT HAVE RECEIVED- AS MUCH- IN
PERSON OR OR AND YOUR CRITICS
INSTRUCTION. OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THAT TO BE MADE UP. ON BOTH IN
THE CURRENT YEAR BUT ALSO IN
THE NEXT. COUPLE YEARS WELL SO
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE
THAT IS FILE ANYTHING JUST TO
KIND OF SPEAK TO THE OTHER
MEMBERS QUESTION CAN HELP KIN
OF ALL. KIND OF COME FULL
CIRCLE YOU KNOW THAT THE
PURPOSE AROUND INCLUDING THE
HYBRID MODEL WAS TO ENSURE
THAT- SOME SCHOOLS WHO HAVE
MAYBE YOU KNOW. IMPACTED
FACILITIES ARE LIMITED CAPACITY
REGARDING A TEACHERS- CAN
PROVIDE AT LEAST YOU KNOW ANY
STUDENT WHO WANTS TO RECEIVE AT
LEAST SOME IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECEIVE THAT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. WHILE FEELING SAFE
AND WELL YOU KNOW IT SURE
ENOUGH. BUT THERE'S THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN PLACE- AND THAT
AND THE COMING NEXT
REQUIREMENTS ARE BEING MET-
THAT PARENTS FEEL COMFORTABLE
SENDING THEIR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL AND SO. REALLY YOU KNOW
THIS IS THIS IS A DIFFICULT
ISSUE IN REBOUNDING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES BUT I
THINK WE DID A GREAT JOB IN
TERMS OF. THAT CONTRACT WE CAME.
UP WITH AND BALANCING ALL OF
THOSE PRIORITIES. SORRY CENTER
DRAWS DID YOU HAVE. OTHER IT
SAID THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SO GO
TO SENATOR. IS A MENTION PAM.
AND THEN MAY- ALL OF OUR
DIFFERENT- SHIELDS HERE MAKE
THE REFLECTION HARD SOMETIMES
FOR ME TO SEE IF YOUR MIKE'S UP
SO- WAVE YOUR HAND IF I HAVEN'T
RECOGNIZED YOU. BUT LET US GO
TO SENATOR MELINDA IS AND THEN
SENATOR PAN GO AHEAD SENATOR
MELINDA. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
SO. IN IN THIS BUILD VERY
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION GIVEN TO.
SCHOOL'S ROCKING OFFERING IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO- THE
MORE- REMEMBER HOW A REFERENCE
TO THE BELL BUT THOSE WHO ARE
MORE AT RISK OF BEING NEGLECTED
OR ABUSED OR THINGS LIKE THAT
AND I JUST. CURIOUS IF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS LOOKED AT
THE NUMBERS NATIONALLY RELATING
TO OUR- THE INCREASE IN ABUSE
AND NEGLECT AND IF THAT WAS
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION I
GUESS I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW.
HOW ARE THE STUDENTS IDENTIFIED
IS THAT STUDENTS WHO HAVE A
COMMON SPOKEN TO A COUNSELOR HE
HAD SOME. ISSUE AT HOME IT'S
ALREADY DOCUMENTED IS THAT HOW
WE ARE IDENTIFYING IDENTIFYING
THOSE KIDS WHO ARE AT THIS
PARTICULAR RISK. HI ASHLEY WITH
A PERMANENT FINANCE- I THINK
AND I TOTALLY WE'VE DEFINITELY
BEEN HEARING THAT ABUSE AND
NEGLECT ARE ON THE RISE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY I DON'T HAVE. ANY
NUMBERS TO SHARE WITH YOU BUT
AND HAPPY TO GO BACK AND GET
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION I'M
SORRY. SO MY QUESTION MY
QUESTION SORRY IS I JUST DON'T
WANT YOU TO RESPOND YES OR
SOMETHING I THINK IT'S R. TWO-
MY QUESTION IS HOW ARE. HOW ARE
THESE AN INMATE THIS MAY NOT BE
A QUESTION FOR THE LA YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY BUT OUR THE STUDENTS
WHO WERE PLACED IN THE CATEGORY
OF BEING MORE AT RISK FOR
NEGLECT. OR ABUSE. IN THAT
CATEGORY. MMHM HOW ARE THEIR-
YES BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE JESSICA
HOLMES HAVE- MORE DETAILS THANK
YOU. CERTAINLY I'M JUST GONNA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I AM BY
NO MEANS I'M AN EXPERT IN THIS
DAY I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO FOCUS
ATTENTION ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES UNIT THAT THAT MIGHT
BE A LITTLE BIT BETTER IN TERMS
OF ANSWERING THE QUESTION BUT I
DO KNOW THAT THERE'S A LEGAL
DEFINITION. OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
AT RISK FOR ABUSE NEGLECT AND
IT IS RELATED TO- FORMAL
IDENTIFICATION THERE'S A
PROCESS- AND- I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO COME BACK WITH MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT THAT
THAT THAT THAT THAT'S- SORT OF
THE HIGH LEVEL INFORMATION I DO
HAVE. OKAY AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I DON'T MEAN TO PUT
YOU ON THIS ONE I'M JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE IT SEEMS
TO ME LIKE- THESE ARE STUDENTS
THAT WOULD HAVE ALREADY HAD TO
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED. BITE YOU
KNOW EITHER STATE AGENCY ORDERS
ALL RIGHT THAT IS NOT TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT. THE INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
NOW BEING NEGLECTED OR ABUSED
IN SOME WAY SHAPE OR FORM
BECAUSE- IS PANDEMIC BECAUSE
THEIR HOME. ALL THE TIME FOR
THE LAST YEAR I DON'T THINK
IT'S TAKING INTO ACCOUNT SO
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN HERE- I THINK SOME OF THAT
IS. TO ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS IS
THAT. YEAH OR- SUMMER SCHOOL IN
A OTHER. EDUCATE UP. YEAH THERE
ARE THERE ARE- THE USES OF THE
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION DO
INCLUDE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL-
MENTAL HEALTH AND STRESS AS
WELL. OKAY MAYBE USE FOR THOSE
ACTIVITIES. IN ADDITION TO OUR
SUMMER SCHOOL OPPORTUNITIES OR
OTHER. EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY- WELL. I GUESS I WILL SAY
THAT I AM HAPPY TO SEE THAT OUR
LEAD MINISTRATION RECOGNIZES
THE- UNSPEAKABLE HARM THAT HAS
BEEN DONE TO OUR STUDENTS WITH
RESPECT TO. THE INCREASE IN THE
GLASS INCREASING YOUR VEHICLES-
DOESN'T MAKE ME FEEL BETTER
KNOWING NOW THAT. THIS MONEY IS
NEEDED NOW TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THAT WAS CREATED BY THE STATE
BY WALKING SCHOOLS DOWNPOUR
HERE WE'VE HAD SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE BEEN OPEN FOR MANY MANY
WEEKS NOW IN SOME CASES MONTHS
HAVE BEEN OPERATING JUST FINE
WITHOUT INCIDENT. THE MAJORITY
OF THE STATE IN THE PURPLE TEAR
I'M NOT HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY-
I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT OFFERING
SUMMER SCHOOL IS GOING TO BE-
SAVING GRACE ORGANS. YOU CAN
READ WHAT IS HAPPENING AND I'VE
SEEN IT IN MY OWN KIDS RIGHT
THREE IN HIGH SCHOOL- MIGHT
HURT THEIR FRIENDS WHO ARE IN
THEIR GRADES ARE EITHER UP AND
DOWN OR THEY'RE GOING DOWN. AND
THAT I JUST DON'T THINK. SOMERS
AND SOME OF THE OTHER. THINGS
THAT A RECORD IN BILL ARE GOING
TO HELP THEM RIGHT YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT BUT FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE. THIS LOOKS LIKE.
NOT IN NEGOTIATION BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE BUT IN HOSTAGE
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE CTA
AND THE GOVERNOR AND IT
APPEARS. THE CTA'S WINNING-
SEVERAL ARE. THIS IS NOT THE
BILL THAT I WAS EXPECTING THIS
BILL DOES NOT MAKE ME HAPPY
THIS BILL IS. DEPRESSING TO BE
QUITE HONEST WITH YOU- AS A
PARENT OF STUDENTS. AND JUST
DEPRESSING FOR STUDENTS IN
GENERAL WHO ARE HERE FROM ALL
THE TIME I DON'T THINK THIS
BILL. DOES WHAT IT NEEDS TO DO
IT SHOULD BE REQUIRING THAT
SCHOOLS OPEN- BUT IT DOES NOT-
SO RIGHT. I GUESS. I WOULD ASK
YOU IF YOU CAN JUST BRIEFLY
BECAUSE I KNOW WHEN THE MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS- IDENTIFY OR AS
WHAT WHAT. WHAT. THE GOVERNOR
VISIONING THAT ALREADY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO BE
OFFERING ADDITIONAL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES IN SUMMER SCHOOL
IS THAT WHAT THE STUDENTS HAVE
TO LOOK FORWARD TO IN ORDER TO
GET THEIR GRADES UP AND PASS
THESE CLASSES IT WOULD HAVE TO
ATTEND SOME SORT OF HYBRID OR
ON- ONLINE YOU KNOW SOLELY-
EDUCATION TO. TO GET TO WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE FOR THIS WHOLE
YEAR AND WHERE THEY SHOULD HAVE
GONE FOR THE LAST YEAR THE
THICKNESS. YES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- QUESTION JAN YOU'RE
CONCERNED- CENTER MELINDA'S-
I'M ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
BELIEVE THE GOAL IS REALLY TO
IN FACT MORE SCHOOLS TO OPEN
AND TO HAVE AS MANY SCHOOLS
OPEN FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AS POSSIBLE- THE PERSON THAT
YOU'RE CONCERNED THAT IS ALSO
CONCERNED OF THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT'S WHY FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION. IS ALLOWABLE TO USE
FOR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORTS
THERE'S ALSO ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR MENTAL
HEALTH- SUPPORTS TO SCHOOLS.
FIVE THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SO
JUST DIDN'T ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
THAT- AND AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT- A LOT OF STRESS AND-
ANGUISH HAS OCCURRED WITH OUR
STUDENTS AS WELL AS OUR
TEACHERS. AND ATTEMPTING TO
INVOKE GOING BACK TO MY-
COLLEAGUE- MISS HOLMES COMMENT
ABOUT BALANCE- VIEWS ARE THERE
A LOT OF TOUGH DECISIONS THAT
HAD TO BE MADE IN AND THERE IS.
A BALANCE THAT WE ATTEMPTED TO
STRIKE IN REGARDS TO SAFETY AND
TO THE NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS-
AND ALLOWING LOCALS TO DECIDE
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE FOR THEM I
THINK IT. IS AN IMPORTANT
FRAMEWORK OF THIS PROPOSAL- I
GUESS THE IDEA IS TO REALLY USE
THE FUNDS TO INCENTIVIZE GOALS
TO OPEN- THAT TWO MILLION AND
THEN THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
TO PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. SOME OF THAT SUPPORT
MIGHT BE BEFORE SCHOOL IT MIGHT
BE AFTER SCHOOL IT COULD BE AN
EXTENSION OF THE SCHOOL YEAR
COULD BE SUMMER SCHOOL- AGAIN
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF WHAT THAT
SCHOOL AND THAT THE PARENTS AND
TEACHERS DECIDE- BUT YES. IT IS
IT'S- AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT
THERE ARE THAT THERE IS A
BALANCE THAT NEEDED TO BE-
STRUCK HERE AND WE ATTEMPTED TO
DO THAT IN REGARDS TO HOW THE
MONEY WAS DISTRIBUTED. AND FOR
WHAT- PURPOSES THOSE DOLLARS
ARE USED FIRST FOR SCHOOLS THAT
ARE NOT ABLE TO RE OPEN 10% OF
THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION- IS
IT IS SATISFIED FOR. ENHANCED
DISTANCE LEARNING AND TO
PROVIDE- WHAT WE HOPE SCHOOLS
AND TEACHERS AND STUDENTS NEED-
BUT BOTH FOR IN. PERSON AND
DISTANCE LEARNING INSTRUCTION.
OKAY WELL- LIKE I SAID I I'M
GLAD TO SEE THE YOUNG.
ACKNOWLEDGES WRECKING. THE
TRUCK. DAMAGE THE HE'S DONE
WITH THESE. BACK RULES CLOSED
FOR YOUR BUT WE- HAVE MORE TO
DO THANK YOU. SENATOR MELINDA
IS ARE YOU A- DID YOU FINISH
YOUR QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL YEAH. THANK YOU WE WILL GO
TO- SENATOR PAN AND THEN
SENATOR MEN. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I HAVE A FRIEND
COMMENTED THREE QUESTIONS- SO
FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANT BEGIN
BY THANKING- OUR- THE FOLKS
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE I KNOW
OUR BUDGET CHAIR NANCY SKINNER-
SEVEN. ONE CHAIR- LAYERED AND
OUR EDUCATION CHAIR SO LEAVE US
FOR THE HARD WORK AND- HELPING
PUT THIS- GREENMAN TOGETHER AND
JUNCTION WITH THE ASSEMBLY AND
ALSO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE MY
KNOWLEDGE THAT- GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AT LEAST REACH OUT TO MY
OFFICE IS EARLY AS NOVEMBER TO
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE
DO TO TRY TO GET SCHOOLS RE
OPEN. AND AS A PEDIATRICIAN AND
AS A PARENT OF. TWO CHILDREN
WHO. ARE ATTENDING. PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. CERTAINLY THE IS A
ISSUE IS OF- PERSONAL
IMPORTANCE. AND I KNOW THAT
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
PEDIATRICS I HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF TRYING
TO. RETURN TO IN PERSON
LEARNING- SAFELY- AS A WAY TO
BOTH ADDRESS LEARNING ISSUES AS
WELL AS EVEN- MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES RAISE AGE. RELATED TO-
SOCIAL ISOLATION AND-
ACCOMPANYING- DEPRESSION
ANXIETY SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT- WE'VE BEEN. TALKING ABOUT
AND I THINK THAT THIS AGREEMENT
CERTAINLY IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD- AND ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES. I WOULD MAKE
NOTES- THAT- FRANKLY THAT DAY
HERE IN THIS STATE WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL AFFECT
THE ELECTOR SCHOOL BOARDS
THEY'RE LIKE THAT OFFICIALS WE-
MAKE A LOT OF DECISIONS- FOR
SCHOOLS LOCALLY AND FACT HERE'S
A LEGISLATURE WE'VE- ALSO.
TAKEN STEPS TO TRY TO. DIFFER
MORE TO OUR LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
TO- AND- TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT I WOULD POINT OUT THAT-
YOU KNOW ARMED FORCES- OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES HAVE
BEEN SOMEWHAT AND EVEN IN THE
STATE AND- THEY'RE SOMEWHAT
UNEVEN BECAUSE THE STATE HAS
NOT AND- YOU KNOW I. PERSONALLY
I THINK WE PERHAPS SHOULD DONE
MORE BUT I THINK SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WOULD I WOULD
OBJECTED. IF THE STATE WAS
MORE. HEAVY HANDED IN TRYING TO
ENFORCE PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES
AND THEN WE HAVE BEEN AS A
STATE AND INSTEAD DEFERRED MORE
TWO. COUNTIES AND- INCLUDING-
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO
THAT OR NOT TO ENFORCE AND IN
FACT- THAT UNEVEN ENFORCEMENT
IS ALSO CONTRIBUTED TO. A LONG
BLOCK YOU KNOW FOR SO LONG AND-
ISOLATION AND SOME OF THE
EFFECTS THAT PEOPLE REFERENCE
SO I THINK THAT- IS INTERESTING
THAT PEOPLE ARE OBJECTING TO
THE FACT THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
NOT CLOSE ORDERING OR FORCING
OPENING OF SCHOOLS- BUT YET- IF
NOT CALLED ON THE GOVERNOR ALSO
TO A MORE. STRINGENTLY ENFORCE
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES THAT
WOULD HAVE ACTUALLY- PERHAPS
PREVENTED DEATHS AND- AND- MORE
PROLONGED- CHALLENGES WITH WITH
CODED BUT WITH THAT- I DID WANT
TO TRY TO GET TO MY QUESTIONS-
SO FIRST OF ALL. I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT- WE'RE PROVIDING
SOME FUNDS TO BILLION TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO OPEN
EARLY- THAT WE ARE ALSO FOR C.
THREE OPENING- ALSO CALLING ON
THE SURE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FOLLOW PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDELINES
FOR SURVEILLANCE TESTING- IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDS THAT ARE
ALSO PROVIDED IN THIS BILL. I
CAN PERHAPS- SOMEONE CAN SPEAK
TO WHAT STATE IS ALSO DOING TO
PROVIDING THINGS LIKE- PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO SCHOOLS
WE KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO SAFELY
REOPEN SCHOOLS WE NEED TO
PROVIDE MASKS OTHER NEEDS TO BE
VIGOROUS MASK. THE FORCE OF
MASK WEARING END OF LIFE IN
SCHOOLS AS WELL AS OTHER PDP
OUT PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND ALSO THE VEIL
AVAILABILITY OF LOW COST
TESTING I KNOW WE'VE STOOD UP
THE STATE LAB AS WELL SO WHILE
THEY'RE NOT DIRECT BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THEY DO HELP REDUCE SOME OF THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH SAFE
REOPENING AND SOAK- COULD. THE
MINISTRATIONS ADMINISTRATION TO
SPEAK TO WHAT OTHER SUPPORTS%
FOR FIREFIGHTING THE SCHOOLS TO
HELP THEM REOPEN SAFELY IN.
TERMS OF PROVIDING THOSE TYPES
OF. NOT EDUCATIONAL SO. AND
SERVICES TO HELP THEM REOPEN
SAFELY. SENATOR PAT I'M GONNA
TURN THIS QUESTION OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FOR THE DETAILS IN
REGARDS TO PPP AND OTHER-
EQUIPMENT THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU. THE HOME
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YES YOU
ARE CORRECT- SENATOR PAN AND
IDENTIFYING THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN SEVERAL OTHER INITIATIVES
THAT HAVE BEEN GOING ON ON THE
OUTSIDE OF THIS PROCESS TO HELP
SCHOOLS AND GET THAT IT'S A
PRIVATE THEY NEED. TO PROVIDE A
SAFE AND HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
WHILE BRINGING STUDENTS BACK IN
PERSON. AND SPECIFICALLY
INTERESTED IN THE BEGINNING OF
THE FALL THE LAST THE BEGINNING
OF THIS CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR-
THE STATE PROVIDED SIXTY DAYS
WORTH OF PIZZA EVERY SCHOOL IN
THE STATE. AND YOUR COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION- AND THEN
IN ADDITION- CURRENTLY AND I'M
NOT I'M NOT QUITE SURE OF THE
TALENTED AND THIS MAY HAVE
ALREADY GONE OUT OR MAYBE IN
THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW BUT WE
ARE ALSO PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY DAYS OF PPE-
TO SCHOOLS AS WELL AND THAT'S
IN THE FORM OF THINGS LIKE
MASKS- AND GLAD. AND SANITIZER
THE ALL OF THE FATURES ARE
PROVIDING. TICKET TO SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN ADDITION
TO THAT IT YOU MEANT. WE HAVE
BEEN- WE PUT UP THE LUNCH ALAS
AND BOTH INCREASE THE- FROM
PROTESTING ACROSS STATE BUT I
TO. THE OF TESTING ACROSS THE
STATE- AND TRY KEEP FROM THE-
DIFFER. ACCESSING FOR SCHOOL-
AND OUT OF THE PICTURE. TRY TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR SCHOOLS O
DO SOMETHING THAT THEY DON'T
NORMALLY DO WHICH IS PROVIDE
FOR- TESTING THAT COULD BE
NINETEEN TESTING- THAT THAT.
THAT CURRENTLY WE HAVE MORE
THAN A HUNDRED DELEGATES THAT
HAVE ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE
BORN ALIVE RIGHT NOW. AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT MORE ASPECT
PARTICIPATE WE DEFINITELY SEE
THE COST OF THAT GOING DOWN.
EVEN MORE THAN THEY ALREADY
ARE- I KNOW THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY ALSO- RECALL AND
SEEKING A WAIVER FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT FEDERAL
MEDICAID PROGRAM- AND TO TRY
TO. ENSURE THAT ANY STUDENT
TESTING FOR STUDENTS WHO
QUALIFY FOR MEDICAID. AND IT'S
COVERED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON. SOME REALLY
HARD WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO TRY TO OBTAIN.
THERE ARE SEVERAL AND YOU KNOW
AND YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT INITIATIVES
OUTSIDE THE PROCESS THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON TO. TRY TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE THAT THAT HEALTHY AND
SAFE. ENVIRONMENT OKAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE ANSWER SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE THIS
TYPE SUPPORTS AND- JUST WON'T
RECOGNIZE IT THERE IT DOES OUR
EXPENSES THAT- THAN EITHER THE
STATE OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WOULD BE TAKING ON THAT WOULD
HELP US OPEN SCHOOLS SAFELY.
AND WHAT NOT AND HOPEFULLY NEED
TO COME OUT OF THE FUNDS THAT
WERE OUT PUTTING INCLUDING IN
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. BUT THE
NEXT QUESTION I HAVE IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. AND GENERAL FUND FOR
THE STATE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL
TEAMS. I THINK AT THE END IN
PREVIOUS ITERATIONS ADVERTS
THAT WE PROVIDE A SUFFICIENT
FUNDING FOR THEM SO THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE THE KIND OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THESE ARE
YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS- THE
TEACHERS AND STAFF- ARE WORKING
VERY HARD TO. THAT WHILE THERE
ARE SCHOOL NURSES TO BRING
HEALTH EXPERTISE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT. WE PROVIDE THAT
KIND OF SUPPORT SO CAN YOU
SPEAK PERHAPS A LITTLE. ABOUT
WHAT THAT DOES FUNDS BE KIND OF
A PASS YOU'RE GOING TO IN THE
STATE SCHOOL FOR ALL TO UP THIS
FUN FOR THAT THIS FUNDING WE
CONTRIBUTE SET THIS HELP THE
SCHOOL THIS. FIELD REAL SAY OR.
I AM HONORED. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE YES FIVE MAY.
A ABOUT. FORCED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE DISTRICTS
THAT OULD NEED IT IN REGARDS
TO ANY QUESTIONS THEY MIGHT
HAVE FOR RE OPENING- ALL ALONG
THE POLICIES INCLUDED FIVE-
REQUIRED THROUGH. RECEIPT OF
THE GRASS- BUT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO JESSICA HOLMES IS HERE
SHE HAS MORE DETAILS IN TERMS
OF CAPACITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CERTAINLY TO THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT YOU
REFERENCED IS AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
COGNITIVE STATUS THE SCHOOLS
FOR ALL TEAMS- IN ADDITION TO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. FUNDING
IS AVAILABLE FOR ENFORCEMENT-
AND ALSO TO YOU- PROVIDE AN
EDUCATION TO THE EXTENT THAT A
SCHOOL IS HAVING ISSUES WITH
THINGS LIKE AN OUTBREAK. SO BUT
THE BILL ACTUALLY INCLUDE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRES THAT ANY SCHOOL SITE
THAT HAS. TWO OUTBREAKS OF CODE
THAT NINETEEN- THAT THE STATE
SCHOOLS FOR ALL TEAM WOULD COME
IN AND DO AN AUTOMATIC SAFETY
REVIEW- SO THAT'S AT YOU KNOW A
NEW PIECE THAT EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PIECE- AND- AND THE
IDEA THERE IS. TO ENSURE THAT
NUMBER. THE TYPICAL CROPPING
CAN LOOK AT WHAT THE PLAN IS
THE CURRENT THANK YOU PLAN HOW
THING EXECUTED TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
ELEAZAR. ON THE HOW THE FULL
SITE TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
MAKING THE CORRECTION IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT HEALTH
AND SAFETY CAN BE. ENSURED IN
AN IN PERSON STARTING-
ADDITIONALLY. AS WE HAVE NOTED%
BEFORE AND WE DO HAVE. A A FREE
PHONE NUMBERS THAT AND ANYONE
IN THE COMMUNITY CAN CALL IN IF
THEY HAVE CONCERNS. ABOUT THE
CONDITION THAT THEIR SCHOOL FOR
IN PERSON LEARNING- TO HAVE THE
STAPLES FOR ALL CAN COME OUT
AND TAKE A LOOK AND MAKE SURE
THAT THINGS ARE BEING DONE. I'M
IN A HEALTHY AND SAFE MANNER
AND AGAIN. YOU KNOW THE INTENT
HERE IS NOT TO BE PUNITIVE BUT
TO BE PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
TO ENSURE. THAT WE CAN KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN THE SCHOOLS AND THAT
IT CAN BE DONE SO SAFELY. SH
I'M LOOKING I WOULD NOTE ON THE
FUNDING IS THAT WE ARE ALSO.
WORKING ON- WHAT THE HIRING
WILL BE WHAT AT WITH THAT
CAPACITY BUILDING WILL ACTUALLY
LOOK LIKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WHEN THE WORKING
ON THAT. AND THEY WILL BE
PROVIDING- AN EXPENDITURE PLAN
AND REPORT TO THE JAIL BC FOR
THE LEGISLATURE'S. REVIEW I'M
PRIOR TO THE EXPENDITURE OF
THOSE FUNDS SO. THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS TO THINK
WHAT THE EXPENDITURES WILL
SUPPORT. TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ON THE SAME PAGE IN AN
AGREEMENT. WHAT THAT WHAT THAT
ADDITION SUPPORT SHOULDN'T LIKE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR ANSWER I
THINK IT IS A IMPORTANT HAVE
THAT- PUBLIC HEALTH THE PART TO
BE ABLE TO IF THERE ARE L.
SINCE. FAILED TO GATHER DATA WE
HAVE THAT IF SO WE KNOW
REMOVING HOW TO SCHOOLS.
SEVERAL OTHERS RESEARCH OUT
THERE NEED TO GET THE AROUND SO
EXTREME IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
CONTACT TRACING AND OUTBREAKS
THAT ARE DATA FIVE POSITIVE
CASES AND SO FORTH AND- I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT THE EARLIER I
DID RAISE CONCERNS THAT WITH A
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICT WE
NEED MORE CAPACITY BILL TO HELP
ALL OF THEM AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT'S BEING DONE THROUGH
THIS ALLOCATION. I WOULD ALSO-
JUST MAKE NOTE THAT- THAT YOU
KNOW- BUT THAT IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE ACTUALLY
DID NOT TRY TO CODE OF FIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE BUT
ALLOWED PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE
TO FOLLOW THE SCIENCE BECAUSE
WE KNOW WE CONTINUE TO GATHER-MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
VIRUS THE VARIANCE- ETCETERA SO
IT'S AGAIN IN ORDER SURE THAT
WE- STAY ON TOP OF SCHOOL
SAFETY THAT- WE ACTUALLY BE
ABLE WE CAN DEFER TO THE PART
OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOLLOW THE
LATEST SCIENCE ON THE PANDEMIC
AND THEN FINALLY MY LAST
QUESTION. I APPRECIATE THAT-
WE'RE GOING TO BE PRIORITIZING-
SCHOOL WITHOUT TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL STAFF AND CHILD CARE-
WORKERS AS WELL FOR BACKS FOR
THE FOR THE FIRST TEST OF THE
VACCINES- AND- I DECIDE
CLARIFIED THAT ONCE THEY HAVE
ALL BEEN OFFERED THE VACCINES
THAT WE ARE- I CERTAINLY WOULD
WANT TO CONTINUE TO OFFER THEM
VACCINATIONS AND THAT'S GOING
TO BE. AN IMPORTANT PART OF.
THE SCHOOL SEE YA TERMS OF.
TRYING TO PREVENT ANY OUTBREAK
IN SCHOOLS BETWEEN STAFF
MEMBERS. THAT- THIS PROVISION.
WILL ALSO ONCE WE HAVE OFFERED
TO ALL THE- THE PEOPLE IN THE
CATEGORY THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
CALL. WHEN I GET THAT WELL
BASICALLY THAT WE CAN BE SURE
WE CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
THE VACCINES INTO THE GENERAL
POPULATION- LOUD IN ADDITION.
YES CENTER PANAMERICAN LEE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND
YES THE 10% IS A MINIMUM ON A
WEEKLY BASIS TO PROVIDE TO THE
EDUCATION WORKFORCE- AND
OBVIOUSLY THE GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE- READY ACCESS AS WELL
AS I. MEAN OPPORTUNITY AND-
QUICK- DOES ACCESS TO THE
VACCINATIONS FOR THIS GROUP-
AND IN REGARDS TO- YOU KNOW THE
GOAL OF. OF DEATH IS IT IS BY
THE END OF THE SUMMER TO HAVE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
VACCINATED. AND STARTING WITH
THIS CAR ABOUT FOR TEACHERS IS-
THE BEST WAY TO GET MORE
SCHOOLS OPEN AND WILL CONTINUE
TO OFFER THAT- MINIMUM OF 10%
TO THIS COHORT. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH- BUT MAY NOT THAT TO
LEAVE SEEN AND HOW CARE FOR SO.
WHICH ARE COMPOSED OF PEOPLE IN
GROUP ONE AA THAT WE ACTUALLY
SEE A DRAMATIC DROP IN THE-
NUMBER OF CASES OF COVERT
HOPEFULLY OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS WILL DO THE SAME
AND- VARIOUS- ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE WORK
WILL. WILL VIGOROUSLY URGE
THEIR MEMBERS TO GET VACCINATED
SOON CAN SHE THOSE LEVELS OF
VACCINATION. AND APPRECIATED
THIS OPPORTUNITY IS THERE
FINALLY JUST WANT TO SAY THAT-
UNITED OPPORTUNITY GO TO A
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MY OWN
DISTRICT US ELK GROVE UNIFIED
YESTERDAY. AND TALK TO
SUPERINTENDENT ABOUT THE
VARIOUS CHALLENGES SO I KNOW
THAT PEOPLE HERE RAISING ISSUES
ABOUT THE HYBRID AND- YOU KNOW
SCHOOLS GOING TO REALLY BE OPEN
AND SO FORTH AND I. YOU KNOW
HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO THE
TEACHERS AND THE SUPERINTENDENT
AND OTHERS. THEY WANT TO OPEN A
SHIFT AND OPEN IS NOT REALLY
THE RIGHT WORD THEY WANT TO GO
BACK IN PERSON BE BEEN OPENED
EVEN TEACHING. THE DISTANCE
LEARNING BUT THEY WANT TO GET
BACK IN PERSON AND THEY REALLY
DO. AND THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY HARD AT IT. YEAH THERE'S
ACTUALLY A CHALLENGES FOR
EXAMPLE THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SOME STUDENTS ARE IN YEAR
ROUND- SOME STUDENTS ARE YOU
KNOW MORE TRADITIONAL
SCHEDULES- YOU KNOW IT'S THE OF
DIFFERENT BREAK SCHEDULES-
DIFFERENT SUMMER SCHEDULES
ETCETERA. AND IT'S HARD FOR US
UP HERE IN THIS CHAMBER TO SIT
THERE AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DICTATE THAT TO THEM. AND I
THINK MANY OF US OFTEN TIMES-
NETFLIX MY COMMENTS ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL IS THAT WE DO THAT- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. BABY ONE SIZE
FITS ALL ISN'T NECESSARILY THE
BEST WAY TO GO AND SOMETHING AS
SPECIFIC AS IN PERSON LEARNING
SO. I DO APPRECIATE THAT IN
THIS PARTICULAR BILL WE ARE
INCENTIVIZING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
I THINK THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WANT TO DO
THIS. AND THAT- AND THAT- YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT TRYING TO BE
OVERLY RESTRICTIVE AND TELLING
THEM HOW TO DO IT AS MUCH AS-
GIVING THEM A PRETTY GOOD
KNOWLEDGE AS WELL AS THE
RESOURCES WHICH ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO DO IT SAFELY. SO
IT THAT. I URGE SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
P. NOW WE HAVE. A SENATOR MITCH.
AND FOLLOWED SENATOR NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BY THE
NUMBER THAT BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
ONE ON EDUCATION AND A FATHER
THREE KIDS WHO I HOPE OUR ON
ZOOM RIGHT NOW ATTENDING THEIR-
ONLINE CLASSES I JUST TO SAY
AND I AM ABSOLUTELY THRILLED
ABOUT THIS AGREEMENT TO RE OPEN
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION OR NOT K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS. I AM
GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM OUR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP AND ALL
OF THE MANY STAFF THAT WORKED
SO HARD ON THIS DEAL- IN
BALANCING A LOT OF COMPETING
INTERESTS INCLUDING- WHAT THE
SCIENCE TELLS US ABOUT COVIDIEN
SAFETY. WITH THE DESIRE TO
RESUME AND GET BACK TO
NORMALCY- MITIGATING THE
LEARNING LOST THE TWENTY
TWENTIES BROUGHT ON AND- YOU
KNOW I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
AGAIN THAT THIS IS A TOUGH
TOUGH- SITUATION. IS STATEWIDE
PRIORITIES BALANCING THAT WITH
LOCAL CONTROL SOMETHING MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF KIDS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE SUFFERING AT
THE SAME TIME WE KNOW THAT
COVERT NINETEEN HAS CLAIMED
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
LIVES IN THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING. MANY THOUSANDS IN MY
DISTRICT IN SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTY SEVEN I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION REALLY BRIEFLY THAT I
AM GRATEFUL FOR THE DO NO HARM
PROVISION FOR THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE OPENED
ALREADY. THIS WAS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT IN MY PART OF ORANGE
COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
RESUMED EITHER FULLY IN PERSON
ARE HYBRID MODELS OF
INSTRUCTION- AND SO THAT DO NO
HARM PROVISION IS- IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I KNOW
THAT MY ELEAZAR WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THIS WOULD MADE
IT INTO THE FINAL. DEAL THAT
WAS STRUCK I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS RELATED TO- THE FALL
SEMESTER- I I'M APPRECIATIVE OF
THE FACT THAT THIS PARTICULAR
DEAL WILL HELP US RE OPEN MANY
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA I DO
THINK IT NEEDS TO BE A PRIORITY
FOR US TO REOPEN ALL SCHOOLS IN
SOME FORM OR ANOTHER- BY THE
FALL IDEALLY FOLEY- I'M A
COMMAND AND A LOT OF. MY LOCAL
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS ARE
TELLING ME THAT. THEY WILL SOME.
ON DISTANCE REQUIRE. FOR CDP-
IF IT'S SIX FEET AS IS THE CASE
NOW THAT'S IF THAT'S A HARD SIX
FEET. I'M TOLD THAT THEY'LL
HAVE TO MOVE TO HYBRID OR OR
SOME SIGNIFICANT COHORT BASED
MODELS- AND I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS HAVE THERE BEEN DISCUSSIONS
WITH CD P. H. R. IN A THIS IS
DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ANTONIO- ON. YOU
KNOW WHETHER THERE MIGHT BE
SITUATIONS WHERE THAT MIGHT BE
RELAXED TO FOUR FEET OR THREE
FEET. HIGH IF CERTAIN OTHER
GUIDELINES ARE MET REGARDING P.
P. E. REGARDING BACKGROUND
INFECTION RATES OR ANY OTHER
FACTORS- IN IF IT'S GOING TO BE
SIX FEET- HOW THAT MIGHT LOOK
GOING INTO THE FALL. MONTHS
WHAT GUIDANCE MIGHT BE GIVEN.
SENATOR ACTUALLY WITH IT OF
FINANCE- I BELIEVE IS A WAIVER
PROCESS IN UNDER REVIEW RIGHT
NOW BUT I WILL- TRY THIS
QUESTION OVER TO JESSICA HOMES
FOR SOME MORE DETAILS. THANK
YOU. IT MADE A- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO VERY RECENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PUT. INTO PLACE THE WAIVER
PROCESS AND ALLOWS A LIAISON
THAT HAD CHALLENGES AROUND
SPECIFIC- HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THE STATEWIDE GUIDANCE- TO
HAVE THEIR TICKET PLANS
REVIEWED BY LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
JURISDICTION IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH- TO. TO
PROVE. TO OTHERS PEOPLE WAIVER
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION- IN AND IN A WAY
THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY FULLY.
COMPLIANT WITH THE GUIDANCE BUT
THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT. OTHER
MITIGATION FACTORS THAT THAT
THE ALLEY A PUTTING INTO PLACE
TO ENSURE HEALTH AND SAFETY. SO
AND ADD THAT THAT AND- I DO
KNOW THAT THAT PROBABLY DON'T
HAVE A TON OF DETAILS ABOUT IT
I'M NOT A PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS. I DO KNOW THAT THAT-
PART OF THAT PROCESS INCLUDES.
LOOKING AT THE- SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS- THAT
ARE IN THE CURRENT GUIDANCE SO-
YOU KNOW HAPPY TO CONNECT YOU
UP WITH SOME OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. AROUND THAT WEEK OR
PROCESS. OKAY YOU VERY MUCH ARE
PRETTY. AND I JUST WANNA. THAT
I THINK THAT GOING TO BE IN AND
I. THINK THAT WE ARE GONNA.
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL.
ARE- OPEN IN SIX. FOR IF NOT
FULLY- BY THIS FALL THERE HAS
TO BE REALLY JUST ARE ARE HARD
BACKSTOP. THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
FOR ALL YOUR WORK. THANK YOU-
NOW SENATOR NIELSEN. THE
FINANCE. FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
WE HAVE. ELIMINATE TESTING. I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING IN THIS
LEGISLATION RELATED TO TESTING
OF OUR STUDENTS TO SEE WHAT HAS
BEEN THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF
THIS DISTANCE LEARNING WE HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO HAVE TO INDOOR
AND IMPOSE ON OUR CHILDREN- HOW
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
TENDING TO ACCOUNT FOR THIS- IN
THE FUTURE HOW WILL WE HAVE A
DEFICIT THAT I REACH STUDENTS
HAVE EXPERIENCED A DEFICIT IN
EDUCATION BASED ON TESTING WELL
HOW WILL WE QUANTIFY. HOW BADLY
OR IF NOT OUR STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN HURT BY THIS DISTANT
LEARNING. THANK YOU. FOR THAT
QUESTION DIRECTLY INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I THINK
THERE IS GENERALLY KNOWLEDGE
MEANT THAT- MANY MANY STUDENTS
ARE. ARE BEHIND IN REGARDS TO
LEARNING AND PART OF THE THAT
WILL A LARGE CHUNK OF THIS-
ALLOCATION OF FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION IS REALLY THERE TO
SUPPORT- THE LEARNING LOSS AND
TO PREVENT FURTHER- LOSS FROM
OCCURRING- IN REGARDS TO
FUTURE- TESTING AND OR OTHER
MEANS BY WHICH TO WEIGH WHAT
THAT LOSS IS- THAT THAT ISN'T.
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT IS NOT PART
OF THIS AND I'M NOT VISION AS
PART OF THIS PACKAGE THIS
PACKAGE IS REALLY MORE GETTING
KIDS BACK INTO SCHOOL- GETTING
TEACHERS BACK INTO SCHOOL FOR
IN PERSON. INSTRUCTION AND
SENDING THEM THROUGH THESE
CRAMPS AND THEN PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL PHYSICAL SUPPORTS TO
HELP THEM ADDRESS SOME OF THAT
LEARNING LOSS- IN THE FUTURE IT
MAY BE NECESSARY FOR TEACHERS
TO- FIND OUT EXACTLY WHERE
THEIR STUDENTS ARE AND TO
MODIFY INSTRUCTION ACCORDINGLY-
BUT THIS. BILL IT REALLY IS TO
GET SCHOOLS REOPENED AND
STUDENTS BACK- IN WHETHER IT BE
IN HYBRID HYBRID OR FULLY BACK.
DEPENDING ON HEALTH AND SAFETY.
YOUR CURRENT AND LET ME FOR THE
J. OF THAT- WE'VE BEEN MOVED IN
THE DIRECTION OF NOT. TESTING
TEACHERS EITHER TO CERTIFY THAT
FOR EXAMPLE THEY ARE COMPETENT
IN MATH AND ENGLISH. IF YOU
HAVE A TEACHER I THINK IT'S CBS
IS ONE OF THE TESTS. OF WE CAN
HAVE A DOUBLE. DOUBLE IMPACT
HERE ON OUR STUDENTS SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT AND SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATION SOME TESTING OF
TEACHERS END OF STUDENTS BE
INCORPORATED. SO WE CAN ASSESS
WHERE WE REALLY ARE- THE CHECK
IT SOUNDS LIKE IN THE NATION
WE'RE STILL VERY NEAR THE
BOTTOM IN. READING AND MATH
STILL. ALL RIGHT LET ME SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WITH MIKE SEVEN. SENATE US
SKEWS ME SENATOR. PHOTO OF BIG
AND THEN SENATOR LARRY. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK-
I HAVE A QUESTION. THE SERVER.%
OKAY I'M THE QUESTIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
CURIOUS TO KNOW HOW DOES THIS
MONEY RELATE TO THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT- MONIES AND THE DEFERRALS
OF DISTRICTS SAW THIS FOR THIS
YEAR. HI I HAVE A QUESTION OVER
TO JESSICA HOLMES. THANK YOU TO
CRITICAL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO UNDERSTANDS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL ARE FINE
THAT ARE AND AT A BILLABLE TO
PROP NINETY EIGHT- FOR BOTH THE
NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR FISCAL
YEAR AS WELL AS THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR TO BE
DEFINED- THAT- WERE INCREASES
TO OUR AFTERNOONS- FOR BOTH OF
THE FISCAL YEARS- AND THAT AS
WE DID NOT ANTICIPATE. ANOTHER
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT- IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY ARE AND HOW
THEY ARE CONNECTED TO THE
DEFERRAL SO I'M WE ARE FULLY
PAYING OFF DEFERRALS AND IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR- WE ARE
PROPOSING AN INCREASE IN
DEFERRALS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUT AGAIN THE SUN- ARE
ALLOCATED OUT OF THE NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEARS. ON THERE ONE TIME
FIND THE NATURE OF THE WOULD
NOT BE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE
USED FOR AN ONGOING BASIS TO
SUPPORT ON GOING FUNDING WHICH
IS- THE PURPOSE AS THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO DEFERRAL IS TO.
RECOGNIZE THAT THE DEARTH OF.
ONGOING FUNDING THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOL. SIR JUST
SO I UNDERSECRETARIES. THESE
FUNDS ARE ASIDE THE THESE ARE
FROM THE- ADDITIONAL MONIES
THAT YOU FOLKS HAVE RECEIVED OR
WILL BE RECEIVING THAT WERE NOT
PLANNED ORIGINALLY. AND IT
EVOKES WE'RE STILL PLANNING ON
PAYING OFF THE DEFERRALS THIS
YEAR AT THE STILL GOING TO BE
IN EFFECT THIS YEAR FOR. I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND I'M SORRY
THE- WHERE DID THE DEFERRALS
FOR THIS YEAR. OF FALL- WITHIN
THE BUDGET YEAH. YOU KNOW
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND A
DEFERRAL PIECES INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX A COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT
TO EXPLAIN MY POLITICS IF I'M
IF I'M BEING CLEAR ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACTUALLY
PROPOSED ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
AND DEFERRALS FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SCHOOL YEAR FISCAL YEAR.
AND HAD PLANNED. YEAH I HAD A
PLAN ON PAYING BACK AND IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEAR WE'RE STILL PLANNING ON
DOING THAT. HOWEVER THE COST
AND THINGS LIKE ALTHEA AND-
COLIJN- AND ONGOING COSTS OF
EDUCATION THAT WE'RE PROJECTING
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
ON INTO FUTURE YEARS- MORE THAN
WE HAVE AVAILABLE IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FINE. AND SO WE
ARE PROPOSING THAT THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION IN DEFERRALS- BE
APPLIED TO THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR FOR ON
GOING COSTS- SHE- AND SO I JUST
WANT TO KIND OF. LAY OUT THE
FACT THAT THE FUNDS THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING FOR THE TWO BILLION
IN THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
R. ONE TIME FINDS- THAT DON'T
DISRUPT OUR ABILITY TO PAY OFF
DEFERRAL. FROM TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FISCAL YEAR THEY'RE DISHING.
OFF ON- ON TOP OF THAT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- AND THEN ONE
OTHER QUESTIONS IS THIS PLANET
AND THIS IS PROBABLY FOR THE-
NOT SURE IF WELL WE ASK. THIS
IS THIS HOW DOES THIS APPLY
THIS BILL APPLY TO SCHOOLS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY OPEN. CAROL HAD
THAT QUESTION AND IF YOU NEED
MORE DETAIL I CAN TURN IT OVER
TO- JESSICA HOME- SO THERE ARE
THE EXISTING AGREEMENTS THAT
ARE IN PLACE FOR SCHOOLS THAT
ARE ALREADY OPEN ARE
GRANDFATHERED IN AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF A SCHOOL IS ALREADY
OPEN- AND THEY HAPPEN TO BE IN
A COUNTY THAT THE PURPLE TEAR.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE TO ADHERE
TO THE- TESTING CADENCE THAT'S
REQUIRED UNDER THAT PURPLE HERE
HONEY HELP- REQUIREMENTS- AND-
YOU KNOW AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE WILL
BE. WILL BE MAINTAINED SO NOT
MUCH AND IN REGARDS TO CHANGES
WILL OCCUR TO THOSE SCHOOLS
THAT I'VE ALREADY- BEEN OPEN
AND I THINK THAT SENATOR MAN
HAD A SIMILAR QUESTION- AND
JUST WE JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT. THIS IS THE DO NOT HARM
THAT THOSE SCHOOLS THAT ARE ARE
ARE ALREADY OPEN- AND REMAINS-
UNTOUCHED BY BY THE SPA
PACKAGE. OKAY AND THEN. CALLED
ME UP WITH THAT AND- ONCE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MADE THEIR
PLAN. THEIR STATE PLAN. TO THE
STATE. WHO ACTUALLY GIVES THE
APPROVAL FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
RE OPEN IS THAT COME FROM THE
COUNTY OR FROM THE STATE FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO PURSUE THE
OPENING. SURE I'M IN- IN
REGARDS TO AGAIN PURPLE PURPLE
TEAR. IN THE COUNT IF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OUR SCHOOL- SUBMITS
THEIR SAFETY PLAN TO BOTH.
THREE MONTHS IN ADVANCE TO
THEIR LOCAL- PUBLIC HEALTH-
OFFICE AS WELL AS TO THE STATE.
AND THAT THE STATE- THEY BOTH
ACTUALLY- REVIEWING IT THEY IT
TAKES ABOUT. FIVE DAYS AND ON
THAT SIX STATES IT'S BEEN
APPROVED THEN THEY MAY REOPEN
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION SIR
APPROVED BY THE STATE OR
APPROVED BY THE COUNTY OR BOTH-
I BELIEVE IT'S BOTH. BUT THE
COUNTY THE STATE. SO BOTH HAVE
TO BE ANGRY TO. OPEN OUR
APPROVED THE PLANS BEFORE
OPENING. YES AND I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT- THE STATE- ALONG WITH
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN IN- MANY
DISCUSSIONS AND- THROUGHOUT
THIS WAS SEVERAL MONTHS SO THIS
WOULD NOT NECESSARILY BE ANY
NEW INFORMATION BUT THERE'D BE
A LOT OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE LOCAL AND STATE.
JURISDICTIONS OKAY. AND THEN
I'M GOING BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST AS A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. ON THE
DEFERRALS- IS IT FAIR M. IS
THIS THE IS SIX POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS PARTIALLY
FUNDED WITH THE CURRENT
DEFERRAL. I'M IN THE HOME- AT
ALL REFER THAT QUESTION DID NOT
MISS HOLMES. CERTAINLY SO I
THINK I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IS THE THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR DEFERRAL
FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND-
TWENTY TWENTY Q. SCHOOL YEAR-
AND WHILE AND PIZZA AND THE SIX
POINT SIX BILLION- COULD BE
USED TO PAY DOWN THAT DEFERRAL
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
YEAR- THOSE FUNDS WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
HE COVER THE COST AS THE
DEFERRAL INTO FUTURE YEARS-
IT'S AN ONGOING DEFERRAL. AND
YOUR ONE TIME SIGN. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IN SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR OF WHAT I THOUGHT I
COULD DO HIS- SPEAK AND TRY TO
TIE TOGETHER A LITTLE A LOT OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD IN
THIS DEBATE BECAUSE THE
DISTRICTS THAT WE ALL REPRESENT
ARE VERY DIFFERENT SENATOR
NIELSEN IS VERY LUCKY TO HAVE
MOST OF THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE
THE LOWEST CASE RIGHT IN THE
STATE AND AS WE HEARD FROM
SENATOR GARAGE SO- SHE HAS
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN HIGHLY
IMPACTED WITH CASES. IN A WAY
THAT THERE'S A BIG CONCERN
ABOUT COMING BACK IN IN MY OWN
DISTRICT I HAVE BOTH I HAVE THE
ABSOLUTE COASTAL AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE REALLY THINK THAT IT'S
EASY TO COME BACK IN THE CASES
ARE LOWER AND THE MORE AWAY
FROM THE COAST AGRICULTURAL
AREAS WHERE THERE'S
INTERGENERATIONAL FAMILIES AND
MUCH MORE DIVERSITY AND THEY
HAVE MANY MORE CONCERNS ABOUT
COMING BACK SO THE REAL
QUESTION IS HOW IN ONE BILL DO
WE ADDRESS ALL THIS. AND
SENATOR GROVE. A MADE THE POINT
THAT SHE REALLY WANTED
CONSISTENT STANDARDS. AND THERE
ARE CONSISTENT. WITH THE
CONSISTENT STANDARDS ARE ABOUT
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT YOU CAN
ADDRESS THOSE DIFFERENT CASES.
AND JUST TAKE FOR EXAMPLE
OCCURS IN A MOMENT I'LL TALK
ABOUT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE THAT. THAT A SENATOR
PAN MENTIONED BUT LET'S JUST
SAY. YOU HAVE A CLASS ROOM
WHERE UNDER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE. YOU CANNOT HAVE FULL
ATTENDANCE IN ONE ROOM DUE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING BECAUSE THE
NUMBER OF KIDS THAT ARE IN THAT
CLASS. AND SO IN THAT CASE. WE
WANT TO GIVE THE FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT IF HALF THE KIDS CAN BE
THERE ONE TIME. AND THE OTHER
HALF CAN BE DISTANCE LEARNING
AND HALFWAY THROUGH THE WEEK
THEY SWITCH. THAT GIVES THE
DISTRICT THE FLEXIBILITY TO
BRING HIM BACK IN THE MAXIMUM
POSSIBLE WAY AGAINST THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE. AND SO THERE
NEEDS TO BE THAT KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY SO PEOPLE CAN PUSH
AS FAR AS THEY CAN WITHIN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE TO DO
IT. AND I THINK THAT THERE BEEN
QUESTIONS RAISED. ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- L. A. TIMES HAD AN
OP ED THAT I DON'T THINK WAS
EXACTLY ON THE MARK. BECAUSE
THEY IMPLIED THAT IT WAS NOT.
THIS BILL IN FRONT OF US WAS
NOT SCIENCE BASED. IN FACT IT
DOES NOT LEGISLATE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE BUT IT REQUIRES
THE PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE AND
LET THE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS DECIDE WHAT THE
GUIDANCE IS. THERE WAS DEBT
EQUAL. INFERENCE IN THAT
EDITORIAL. THAT THIS BILL RICK.
VAX BEFORE TEACH CAN BACK TO
SCHOOL. AND IT DOES NOT IT
FOLLOWS WHAT THE CDC'S SCIENCE
BASED GUIDANCE IS WHICH IS NOT
REQUIRED VACCINATIONS FOR
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES BUT STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THEM THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES SO IT'S
BASED ON SCIENCE AND IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE CDC. AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS SAID HE
WISHES TO PRIORITIZE TEACHERS
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES AS WELL. SO IT IS VERY
CONSISTENT WITH THE FACT. A. N.
ADDITIONALLY. THE EVERY
DISTRICT IS NOT THE SAME SO
IT'S A QUESTION OF HOW YOU
ADDRESS THE NEEDS IN THOSE
DISTRICTS AND- AND I THINK WHAT
SENATOR NIELSEN SOMEBODY
BROUGHT UP CHARTER SCHOOLS IT
AND THE ANSWER SHOWED EXACTLY
THAT FLEXIBILITY. THAT IF THEY
WERE A DISTANCE LEARNING ALL
THE WAY ALONG. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO PAY THEM TO RE OPEN BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN RE OPENED DOING
DISTANCE LEARNING ALL THE WAY
ALONG. THE REAL QUESTION IS IF
THEY WERE DOING IN PERSON WHAT
INCENSE OR SUPPORTS THEM TO
COME BACK IN PERSON. AND THE
REAL CHANGE THAT HAS HAPPENED
DURING THE COUPLE OF MONTHS.
THIS IS BEEN MORE INTENSELY
DISCUSSED. IS A CHANGE IN THE
PANDEMIC. BECAUSE THE TIME
GOVERNOR CRAFTED A PUBLIC
PROPOSAL. IT WAS BASICALLY TO
TRY TO PUSH SCHOOLS TO OPEN.
BECAUSE OF MOST COUNTIES WERE
PURPLE NOT MOVING TOWARD THE
RED END THERE NEEDED TO BE
INCENTIVES TO DO THAT. AND IN
THE COURSE OF THAT DISCUSSION.
COUNTY CASE LOADS OF DROPPED
MANY ARE ON THE VERGE OF
DROPPING INTO THE RED. SO PART
OF THIS SAYS THEY'LL STILL BE A
POLISH WITH MONEY AND
INCENTIVES TO OPEN. BUT TWO
THIRDS OF IT OF THE MONEY SAYS
WILL ACTUALLY HELP PEOPLE RE
OPEN BECAUSE THEY'RE HEADED IN
THE RIGHT WAY IN THE PANDEMIC
AND THEY NEED THE HELP. TO RE
OPEN. IN A AND I THINK SENATOR
DRAWS OR RAISED A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT. WHICH IS IF
YOU FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT SAFE. OR
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'VE BEEN
DISADVANTAGED TO THERE'S A HIGH
CASELOAD. WHAT'S THE ASSURANCE
FOR SAFETY WHAT'S THE ASSURANCE
THAT DISADVANTAGED DISTRICTS
WILL NOT BE LEFT BEHIND. WARNER
RIGHT HERE IT'S THAT IN THOSE
HEAVY CASELOAD LEVELS THAT'S
WHERE THE TESTING WILL BE
THAT'S WHERE THE TESTING. CAN
BE PAID FOR BY THE MONEY. THAT
THE THAT'S WHERE IT ALL
HAPPENED AND ADDITIONALLY
THAT'S WHY PRIORITIZING THOSE
THAT WERE LEFT BEHIND BY
DISTANCE LEARNING FIRST BY
MAKING SURE. IF THEY WERE
FOSTER KIDS FOR HOMELESS KIDS
OR AT THE RISK OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT AS WAS RAISED. FOR
PEOPLE THAT JUST DIDN'T THE
KIDS IT JUST DIDN'T ATTEND. FOR
THOSE THAT DIDN'T HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGICAL ABILITY TO DO
DISTRICTS WARNING OR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS MAKE SURE
THAT THEY THE ONES THAT FIRST
DROPPED OUT. OR THE ONES
PRIORITIZED TO HAVE WE COME
BACK IN SO IT SPEAKS TO THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. IN A
VERY VERY STRONG ONE. AND
ANOTHER THING THAT WAS SAID. IS
THERE WAS AN EMPTY. THAT REALLY
THIS WAS A BILL THAT CATERED TO
ONE PARTICULAR GROUP. WELL IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR SAID WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED SAYS THIS DEBATE WAS
STARTED. AND SOME OF THEM CAME
UP IN THE DEBATE THEY SAID WE-
DON'T WANT TO BE PENALIZED IF
WE'VE ALREADY BEEN OPENED.
THAT'S IN THIS BILL SO THEY'RE
NOT. IT'S SORT OF LIKE IF WE
WERE TESTING WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE TO REINVENT THE WHEEL AND
DO A WHOLE NEW CADENCE THIS
ALLOWS FOR FLEXIBLE PROCESS FOR
THEM NOT TO BE PENALIZED. AND
HAVE THAT PRE EXISTING TESTING
DONE. IF THEY DID A COVERT PLAN
ALREADY IT REALLY SAYS THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO REDO IT IT
INTO I THINK IT WAS SANDRA CHOI
BUGS ARE CONCERNED. THAT THESE
HAVE TO BE APPROVED THERE'S
ACTUALLY A TIME LIMIT ON THEIR
APPROVAL IN THIS BILL SO THAT
IF THEY'RE NOT ACTED ON BY THE
ADMINISTRATORS IT AUTOMATICALLY
IS APPROVED SO THAT. THAT WILL
NOT BOGGED DOWN THE PROCESS AND
INITIALLY THERE WAS A PROPOSAL.
THAT EVERY DISTRICT HAD TO
APPLY. S. AND THIS NO. EVERY
DISTRICT. IS IN A WAY THAT THAT
THAT DOESN'T PUT ANOTHER
BARRIER IN THE WAY. OF RE
OPENING AND SO AN ADDITIONAL IN
A SPEECH TO SENATOR DRAWS
CONCERN. ORIGINALLY FROM THE
MONEY THE WHOLE SIX POINT SIX
BILLION IN THE FIRST
DISCUSSIONS OF THIS. WOULD ONLY
GO TO THOSE THAT WE OPEN EARLY.
AND YET THAT WAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFLUENT
DISTRICTS AND THOSE THAT WERE
BEHIND IN LINE WITH
DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISADVANTAGED DISTRICTS. AND IN
THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS THIS REMOVES THAT. AND
IN THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS REALLY TO OPEN SAT
PEOPLE TO OPEN. IF THEY CAN'T
DO IT BECAUSE PARENTS DON'T
WANT TO SEND THEIR KIDS BACK OR
THE PURPLE LEVEL WAS TOO HIGH.
THEN 10% OF THE OTHER MONEY CAN
BE USED TO HELP THEM RE OPEN IF
THEY RE OPEN. LATELY SO THAT
FLEXIBILITY. IS THERE SO RE.
THIS WAS HARD AND IT IS HARD
BECAUSE WE NEED TO ADDRESS ALL
THE KIDS IN THE FALL THE OVER
ONE THOUSAND DISTRICTS THAT ARE
IN THE STATE AND WE HAVE TO TRY
TO EXPEDITE THE RE OPENING BUT
WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE PEOPLE
FEEL SAFE WHETHER THEY'RE THE
TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM OR
THE PARENTS THEY'RE SENDING
THEIR KIDS BACK AND I THINK
THAT'S THE BALANCE WE TRIED TO
STRIKE IN THIS. SO I FEEL LIKE.
THIS WAS HARD FOR A REASON AND
YOU CAN JUST GET IT BY THE WAY
I'M TALKING ABOUT IT. OVER A
THOUSAND DISTRICTS PEOPLE WITH
HIGH CASELOADS PEOPLE WITH LOW
CASELOADS PEOPLE THAT WANT
THEIR KIDS BACK RIGHT NOW.
PEOPLE THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HEALTH OF PUTTING THEIR
KIDS BACK. TEACHERS DON'T WANT
TO KNOW IF THEY'RE GOING BACK
IN THE PURPLE OF. HERE THAT
THEY ACCESS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES TO PROTECT THEM
IN THE BEST POSSIBLE WAY. AND I
THINK THIS IS GOOD THERE'S A
REASON WHY. IS IT THAT THEY'RE
SORT OF PEOPLE AT THE STRONG
HANDS OF BOTH ENDS OF THIS.
THEY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL. THERE ARE ALWAYS GOING TO
BE CONCERNED THAT WE ARE NOT.
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES AND THOSE
THAT ARE ALWAYS CONCERNED THAT
WE'RE NOT PUSHING HARD ENOUGH
AND YET WE HAD TO HAVE A BILL.
THAT'S FOR EVERY CALIFORNIAN
AND FOR EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT ENTERED ADDRESSES EVERY
SITUATION THAT PEOPLE ARE
FACING AND IT'S NOT A COOKIE
CUTTER APPROACH. IT TO DO NO
HARM. AND ALLOW FOR FLEXIBILITY
FOR LOCAL DISTRICTS SO I THINK.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL THAT TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT ALL THOSE THINGS
AND I ASKED FOR AN ART FORM.
TIMED AS CENTERED LORD WILL
FALL YOU WITH SENATOR KABIR ON
NEVER GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC. AND THEN WE WILL MOVE
TO- TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I. I THAT WAS SUCH
AN OUTSTANDING CLOSING THAT-
THAT I FEEL LIKE THERE'S NOT
MUCH MORE TO SAY OTHER THAN I
WANT TO SAY PERSONALLY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO EVERYONE WHO
WORKED HARD VERY VERY HARD ON
THIS BILL. I HEARD FROM MY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- THEY SENT IN
THEIR CONCERNS AND THE
COMMITTEE TOOK THEM INTO
CONSIDERATION AND MADE THEM
PART OF THE BILL AND SO FOR
THAT I REALLY THANK YOU. FOR
LISTENING TO WHAT THE-
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES WERE
SAYING. AND AND I THINK. ALL
THE STAFF AS WELL AS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR. FOR
REALLY GETTING TO THE NITTY
GRITTY WHICH IS HOW DO WE OPEN
OUR SCHOOLS TO IN PERSON.
LEARNING AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
TAKING THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
THAT IS GOING TO WALK INTO THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT AT HEART SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
FOR. THE OPPORTUNITIES A FEW
WORDS. THANK YOU SENATOR COVER
EURO SO NOW I'VE SEEN NO-
PUBLIC HERE IN THIS GALLERY
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
PUBLIC.IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM
ROOM. ROOM ONE TWO- SORRY
SENATOR DOLLY POLITIES
FRIVOLITIES GO AHEAD SENATOR
LAURIE MANAGER I IN ANOTHER
BUDGET COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO
ASK A QUICK QUESTION CERTAINLY-
WHEN WILL THE WHAT DO YOU
EXPECT THIS BILL TO BE UP ON
THE ON THE FLOOR- OUR HOPE IS
THAT IT WOULD BE TAKEN UP ON
THURSDAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND APOLOGIES THAT I DIDN'T SEE
YOU AS I INDICATED BEFORE YOU
GOT HERE THAT. IT'S OFF IT'S
NOT JUST THAT YOU ARE IN THE
BACK IT'S ALSO THAT ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT SCREENS CREATE SUCH
CLEAR IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO SEE. WHO'S GOT- THERE MIKE'S
UP BUT LET'S CODE AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE I DON'T THINK THERE IS.
BUT LET'S JUST CHECK. ALL RIGHT
SO THEN WE'RE GOING TO GET THE
TELECONFERENCE FOLKS READY- IF
THERE'S ANY HORROR- FOLKS WHO
ARE GOING TO CALL IN FOR THE
TELECONFERENCE. MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PROMPT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. AND THEN LET ME
GIVE THAT PHONE NUMBER AGAIN.
THE PHONE NUMBER FOR THOSE WHO
WANT TO TESTIFY. TO
TELECONFERENCE IS. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. WITH THE ACCESS CODE.
EIGHT SIX ONE ZERO ONE EIGHT
FIVE- SOLE MODERATOR- CAN YOU
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE FIVE PEOPLE IN
THE QUEUE. OKAY GREAT WHY DON'T
YOU LET THEM BEGIN. THANK YOU
AND- I KNOW YOU DO WISH TO
COMMENT I DIDN'T INDICATE FOLKS
PLEASE- IF YOU COULD AS WE
USUALLY DO IN THESE HEARINGS
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO A MINUTE
AND I WILL RETURN TO THE PERSON
IN THE GALLERY AFTER RIGHT
WE'RE OPENING THE LINES NOW AND
THEN A RETURN TO THE PERSON IN
THE GALLERY. OKAY SO WE'RE HERE
FROM THESE FIVE AND THEN I WILL
GO TO THE PERSON WHO'S IN THE
GALLERY. GO AHEAD MODERATOR AND
ONE MINUTE PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR. AND IF
YOU DO TO COMMENT IN. ON A. B.
EIGHTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WHEN YOUR LINE
NUMBER IS CALLED. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD. LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
A PANEL AGAINST REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION. DURING THE
PANDEMIC IT'S BEEN CHALLENGING
FOR ALL OF THEM. WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
COMING TOGETHER UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES TO ADJUST THE RE
OPENING OF SCHOOLS. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT DISTANCE LEARNING AND
CONDITIONS WHICH ARE STUDENTS.
AND THAT THEY'RE FACING- DURING
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAVE
BEEN CHALLENGING FOR THEM TO
SAY THE LEAST. WE STRONGLY
APPRECIATE THE EQUITY FOCUSED
ON AND PRIORITIZATION OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE HOMELESS
FOSTER YOUTH ENGLISH LEARNERS
STUDENTS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY AND DISENGAGED
STUDENTS. AS WELL AS THE
PRIORITIZATION OF SCHOOL STAFF
FOR VACCINATION. WE KNOW THE
PANDEMIC OF HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
BLACK STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND APPRECIATE THE
ATTENTION TO THE STUDENTS IN
THE LEGISLATION. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT SCHOOLS
REQUIRE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF AT THE
PHARMACOLOGICAL SERVICES AND
MENTAL HEALTH. EXTENDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES AND
TUTORING AND OTHER CRITICAL
RESOURCES. WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHTY
SIX AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU. THE LONG TERM NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS IN THE COMING
WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON THIS IMPORTANT. BILL
THANK YOU. I'M MODERATOR THERE
WE'LL JUST GO FOR THE FIRST
FIVE IN THEN WE'LL GO TO WORK%
FOR IN THE- COOK. THANK MADAM
CHAIR MIND. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA TRAN AN
AMERICAN CHILDREN NOW WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURES AND
GOVERNORS EFFORTS TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS AFTER IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION INCLUDING THE NEW
XCELERATED TIMELINE. OUTLINED
IN THE PACKAGE IN ADDITION WE
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
INCLUSION OF ENGLISH LEARNER
PRIOR. TO HER BEING THERE.
EARLIER AND THE DEPARTMENT.
COMMENTS THAT GOING BACK TO IN
PERSON IS OPTIONAL FOR FAMILY.
AND TO CLARIFY IN HIM WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR TO PUT FORTH THE
CLEANUP LEGISLATION ON THAT
POINT BECAUSE EXISTING
STATUTES. READ THE SOMEWHAT
PERMISSIVE AS YOU KNOW THE
PANDEMIC IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
POLLING DATA SUGGESTS THAT
THERE'S A WIDE OF OPINION AMONG
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS.
INCLUDING WIDE VARIATION BY
RACE ETHNICITY AND
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS ON WHEN
FAMILIES AND FEEL COMFORTABLE-
WITH THEIR CHILDREN RETURNING
TO SCHOOL WE WOULD URGE
POLICYMAKERS TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT AS A CONDITION OF
RECEIVING THE DEFENSIVE FRONT.
SCHOOL SHOULD PROVIDE BOTH IN
PERSON LEARNING OPTIONS AS WELL
AS ALLOWS YOU TO CONTINUE IN
DISTANCE LEARNING. WE WERE ALSO
DISAPPOINTED THAT HE REVISED
PROPOSAL STRIKES LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD HAVE PROVIDED GREATER
OVERSIGHT OF DISTANCE LEARNING
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REINSTATE THOSE
COMMISSIONS- TO REQUIRE
DISTRICTS CERTIFY THAT EACH
STUDENT PARTICIPATING IN
DISTANCE LEARNING. HAS A DEVICE
SOFTWARE AND HIGH SPEED
INTERNET ACCESS THANK. YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTEEN LINE IS A- PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE PLEASE. THANK YOU-
MY NAME IS MY- I'M A- ADVOCATE
HE CAN HELP YOU DECIDE IN YOUR
ACTS NETWORK AN AWFUL MEMBER TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF SERVICES
TASK FORCE THIS ONE I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING UP THIS
BILL STRONG SUPPORT OF SPACE ON
THE ISSUES OF EQUITY WHICH HAS
BEEN RAISED IN BOTH HOUSES- NOT
ONLY IN THE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR BUT ALSO IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE- IN THE RURAL
AREAS OF THE STATE. AND LASTLY-
ECHOING THE COMMENTS MADE ON
ISSUES OF OVERSIGHT- WHICH ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR ALL
STUDENTS BUT ALSO THOSE IN
SPECIAL ED AGAIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TAKING UP THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NINE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
BIRDS A LITTLE BIT AFTER WELL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
REPRESENTING TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND SCHOOL THIS IS OFFICER
STATEWIDE. DURING THE PANDEMIC
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES HAVE
BUILT CONTINGENCY PLAN FOR
MULTIPLE BUDGET SCENARIOS AND
STAFFING CAPACITY AS THEY SCALE
UP THERE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AND SERVICES WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF OBTAINING A FORMAL
POSITION AND PLAN TO PROVIDE
OUR SUPPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION BEFORE THE
END OF. TODAY WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THOUGHT BRINGS A BALANCED
APPROACH TO ENSURE THAT SCHOOLS
AND EDUCATIONAL STAFF HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE AS THEY
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE OR BEGIN TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION.
HAVE A GREATLY APPRECIATE AND
FULLY SUPPORTS THE PREPARATION
OF THE FIVE POINT FIFTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS DOLLARS
TARGETED TO SUPPORT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
OPPORTUNITIES. WITH THE
CIVICALLY APPRECIATE THE
GRANDFATHERING AND PROVISION AS
IT STRIVES TO KEEP EXISTING
SCHOOLS OPEN WITHOUT ADDING
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS. THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK OKAY NINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL EXACT DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING EIGHTY
FIVE TRENTON RAIL AGENCIES
ACROSS OUR STATE EACH YOUR
FRONTLINE TRANSIT WORKERS
PROVIDE MILLIONS OF TRIPS TO
KEEP YOUR CALL STUDENTS
CREATING CRITICAL AND DIRECT
ACCESS TO SCHOOLS. DURING THE
PANDEMIC SOME TRANSIT AGENCIES
EVEN CREATED MOBILE HOT SPOT
FOR LEARNING. MORE GENERALLY-
WORKERS RESPONDED ACTIVATION
ORDERS THERE THEY EXPANDABLE
ACCESS. TO TESTING AND
VACCINATIONS BY. BY MEDICAL
TRIPS TO SENIOR AND PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT. YOU KNOW WE'RE IN
THE GUIDELINES FOR BACKING. FOR
THE THAT THE EDUCATION
CHILDCARE. WORKING TO SERVE OR
HEALTH. ARE TRAINED WORKERS
NAME OR GRANTED PRIORITY ACCESS
TO THE BACKSEAT. ISN'T EVEN AT
SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS PERFORMING A
FUNCTIONALLY SIMILAR ROLE ARE
MADE ELIGIBLE FOR THE VACCINE
UNDER THE STATE'S. UNDER THE
EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE
SECTOR. WE'VE COME TO
CONSISTENTLY RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE COMMISSION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TODAY OR
COLLECTIONS THEY TRIED TO
INTERVENE BY PROVIDING DIRECT
ACCESS TO THE BACK NEED. TO
TRADE THE TRUCK LINE WORKERS
FOR US IT REALLY IS A MATTER OF
FACT WHAT HE AT THE MATTER OF
EQUAL ACCESS FOR EQUAL WORK I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO MAKE CHANGES
TO THE STATE'S GUIDELINES. FOR
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HOW MANY GO NOW TO
THE WHICH WHO IS IN THE- IN
PHYSICALLY. GO AHEAD WITH. GOOD
MORNING MATT MADAM AND MEMBERS
MCKAY LEON BEHALF OF THE LOSS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY GOOD
THAT I. FOLLOWED OUR
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT THEIR REQUEST. I L. A.
METRO OBVIOUSLY SERVES THE
ENTIRE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
WHICH INCLUDES THE SECOND
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
NATION. OUR OUR- BUS DRIVERS
AMONG OTHERS ARE FRONT LINE
WORKERS. ARE PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND WE
SUPPORT CTAS REQUEST TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO TREAT THOSE
FRONT LINE WORKERS. IN THE SAME
MANNER AS WE DO OTHER TRANSIT
WORKERS SERVING IN THE
EDUCATION AND CHILD CARE
SECTORS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU- NOW MODERATOR WILL
GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LINE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WE WERE
TALKING ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. I. Q. WOULD ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THE TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTATIVE AND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA METRO.
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY TRANSPORT THOUSANDS
OF- SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN EVERY
DAY TO THEIR SCHOOLS- AND WE DO
THINK IT'S A MATTER OF EQUITY
IN ORDER TO URGE YOU. TO
RECONSIDER AND- GIVE PRIORITY
TO OUR BUS DRIVERS. IN THE SAME
MANNER AS OTHER TRANSPORTATION
WORKERS IN THE EDUCATION SECTOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AIR
NAPPY WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
ALIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS AND
OUR COLLEAGUES THAT CHILDREN
NOW E SIMILARLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
EFFORTS THREE OF THE COLD
SPRING PERSON INSTRUCTION. YEAH
SEPARATELY THE CONTINUED
INCLUSION OF ENGLISH LEARNERS
IN THE GROUP I NEED YOU TO BE
SERVED IN ALL GRADES AND
COLORED HERE WE SUPPORT THE NEW
REQUIREMENT FOR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS IN PURPLE TEARS ARE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR TKT
SECOND GRADE. ALTHOUGH WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO EXTEND ITS
REQUIREMENTS THROUGH THE SIXTH
GRADE HELLO WE'RE EAGER FOR
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS TO RETURN
TO SCHOOL IN PERSON WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE PANDEMIC IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
LOW INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THERE'S A WIDE RANGE OF
COMFORT LEVEL AMONG PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS ABOUT WHEN AND HOW
THEIR CHILD RETURNS TO SCHOOL
IN PERSON DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WE ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT AS A CONDITION FOR RICKY
DEFINE WHAT MIGHT CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THE OPTION OF HIGH
QUALITY DISTANCE LEARNING THIS
YEAR. LASTLY WE ARE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FOUR POINT
SIX BILLION EXTENDED LEARNING
FIND VALUE SHARE A PROBLEM AND
ALL CONCENTRATION CLASS. RATHER
THAN USING THE FALLOUT VIA
FORMULA WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED EFFORTS ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND FOR
PRIORITIZING STUDENTS THAT ARE
HARD TO. THANK YOU. RIGHT OKAY
NINE SEVENTEEN YOUR IS OPEN
PLEASE GO. HI GOOD MORNING MY
CHAIR MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS EVA
COUNTRY WHAT THAT'S OF CAL
SCHOOL. ACCESS PLEASE SUPPORT
SB EIGHTY SIX THE END OF ANTI
ON EQUITY AND IT WILL MORE RAP
AND READ TO THE BACK INTO
CLASSROOM. THANK YOU TO EACH OF
THE COMMITTEE LEADERS AND GET
US TO THE COMPROMISE. ALSO TO
EXPAND OUR TO THE STAFF THE
TIME AND ENERGY AND IN THE BELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
MODERATOR MANY AND QUEUE. AT
THIS TIME WE FOR THE Q. OKAY GO
AHEAD. MY TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR SKINNER AND
ON THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KELLY AND WHAT WAS SPEAKING
MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT AC TRANSIT WE SERVE
PORTIONS OF ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA I TOO WOULD
LIKE FILLING MY COMMENTS
BECAUSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ELLEN MY CHILD.
I THINK IN THIS MORNING TO URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER THE LAW THAT
PUBLIC TRANSIT PLAYS IN THE RE
OPENING OF SCHOOLS PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC A TRANSIT CARING FOR
POUNDS STUDENTS CALL EACH DAY
WE'VE GOT HOME TO SCHOOL. HOME
TO BUT- FOR STUDENTS THE ENTIRE
SERVER AREA THIS SERVICE IS
PROVIDE BY THE BEYOND THE
SERVICE PROVIDED TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AND THOUSANDS OF RELY ON
IT TO GET SEARCH TO. EVERY DAY
MANY OF THE FAMILIES RELY ON
OUR SERVICE I'M FROM THE LOW
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THAT
HAVE BEEN IN BY THE- AS WE SAY
IN OF ACTING EDUCATORS WE OUR
SCHOOL IT CRITICAL PUBLIC TRY
WORKER ARE. ENGRAVED B. SURE
ONE OF THE SCHEDULE OPERATORS
HAVE PROVIDED CRITICAL SERVICES
TO COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC GETTING ESSENTIAL
WORKERS TO CALL AND ARGUE
COMMUNITY FOR MEDICAL. IN
OAKLAND IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
OPERATORS ARE PEOPLE TO THE
MASS VACCINATION SITE AT THE
COLISEO. WE RESPECTFULLY- THAT
TRYING WORKERS BE PRIOR FOR
VACCINE AT SCHOOL RE OPEN THE
SCORING PLANS MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THE
TARGETING OF STUDENTS IN THE
GREATEST NEED IN THE BILL- AND
HAVING THEM RETURN IN THE
COHORT MODEL AS THIS WILL BRING
AND- STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET THE ATTENTION THAT
THEY REQUIRE. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE VACCINATION
PLAN. HAS WRITTEN AND KNOW THAT
IT'S- TAKES A GREAT LENGTH AND
HOW IT REALLY HELPS OUR
MEMBERS- FEEL SAFE. AND BE SAFE
IN RETURNING TO WORK- AND FOR
THE AGENT TO MATTER CASTING IN
THE LOCAL REGION. HOWEVER WE
ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
ASYMPTOMATIC TESTING IS AND
ALSO PRESENT THE RED TIER AS
REFLECTED IN CURRENT CDPH
GUIDANCE. WE THINK THIS IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT WE
DON'T FALL INTO THE TRAP OF
MIXING HOUSEHOLDS AND NOT
CATCHING. POTENTIAL SPREAD THAT
THAT WOLD REQUIRE ANOTHER
CLOSURE OF THE SCHOOL AFTER
RETURNING TO IN PERSON WHAT ARE
YOUR YOR FACTS. I WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE STRONGER ENFORCEMENT
LANGUAGE GIVEN THE MANY STORIES
VEGETATION STAFF. THAT HAVE
BEEN TOLD TO COME IN TO WORK
WITH FEVERS- SEEING DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS BEING IGNORED
ANOTHER ANECDOTAL STORIES THAT
SHOW. A LACK OF ENFORCEMENT
PRESENTS A- CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
UNRAVELS ALL THE GREAT WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THIS DEAL WE
APPRECIATE. IT BACK HERE THEN-
INCREASED IN IN THAT STRETCH. I
APPRECIATE. ALL THE WORK AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M MOVING ON
TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT. NINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR THAT CHRIS
RESPONSIBLE AT WHAT CONCERN
AMONG POVERTY- HERE IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. EIGHTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS ANDREA BALL
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT LED TO THIS BALANCED
COMPROMISE WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD. THE
DISTRICT I'M TALKING ABOUT ARE
QUITE VERY VERY SMALL VERY
LARGE IN ALL PARTS OF THE STATE
THAT YOU. TALKED ABOUT THIS
MORNING. SO FINDING A
COMPROMISE THAT WORKS FOR ALL
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE AND WE
APPRECIATE THIS NEEDS RESOURCES
ARE VITALLY NEEDED TO BRING
MORE STUDENTS BACK SAFELY VERY
SOON. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YOUR AVAILABLE LINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM- MY
DIMENSION THIS IS- WHEN THE
MONSTER FROM SANTA CRUZ METRO-
BUT UP UNTIL LEGISLATIVE AND-
NO THIS CONTRACT WITH METAL
PLAYS A SIGNIFICANT ROLE DIDN'T
TRY PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES STUDENTS. ALSO OUR
OPERATORS REALLY PLAYS- THIS IS
A GREAT ROLE IN PROVIDING
SERVICE TO FORTY NINERS AND
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND WILL
REQUEST- OUR SYSTEM BACK
SUPERBOWL TRYING TO IT'S JUST
NOT COME. AS AND OTHER TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE ADVOCATING FOR
AND- WE SAW WHERE. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANKS
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME EXCELLENT
SO- WE WILL COME BACK TO ORDER
SENATOR NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND QUERY FINANCE IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY PULL FIRST
WOULD BE THE EARLIEST THESE
SCHOOLS COULD BE OPENING.
ELEMENT FORM DIET THAT THAT
DURING SPRING BREAK. IN FACT
GOOD FRIDAY IS APRIL SECOND. DO
THOSE DATES NEED TO BE THAT
CHANGED RELIGION ARE A BIT OF A
CONFLICT THERE COULD FINANCE AS
OF THAT DATE QUESTION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT- YES
ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND I'M I'M I'M NOT
pDISTRICTS- SPRING BREAK AND SO
I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT SENATOR NELSON. IF YOU
WOULD I THINK THAT THERE COULD
BE SOME POTENTIAL CONFLICT AND
DIFFICULTIES WITH THESE DATES
BECAUSE PROBABLY THE DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS DO INDEED HAVE
DIFFERENT. BACK TO SCHOOL DATES
FOR SPRING BREAK DATES SO
PLEASE DO CHECK ON THAT. I
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- BEFORE. I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WANT TO MAKE
A COMMENT MYSELF AND THEN I
WANT TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION- AND
I WILL CALL ON SENATOR LAYERED
FOR THE MOTION- I WANT TO.
REALLY GIVE MY APPRECIATION TO
THE STAFF THAT HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS LITERALLY SINCE
DECEMBER AND THOSE ARE STAFF IN
BOTH HOUSES- AND- MANY OFFICES
AND OF COURSE IN WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION ADDITIONALLY AND
OF COURSE MANY MANY MEMBERS
HAVE ALSO. BEEN SPENDING MANY
HOURS ON THIS AS WELL AS
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND THERE WERE VARIOUS
REFERENCES IN THIS DEBATE TO
CERTAIN STAKEHOLDER SOMEHOW
GETTING MORE THAN OTHERS AND- I
STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH THAT
ASSERTION. THIS IS HARD AS
SENATOR LAYERED POINTED OUT.
THE DETAILS MATTER. AS MUCH AS
THERE ARE VERY LEGITIMATE
REASONS TO GET OUR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL SOME FAST AS POSSIBLE.
IN MANY PARENTS WHO WANT THAT
THERE ARE ALSO MANY PARENTS WHO
ARE AFRAID AND ARE CONCERNED TO
HAVE THEIR CHILD GO BACK TO
SCHOOL AND POTENTIALLY BRING
THE VIRUS BACK INTO THEIR HOMES
AND PUT SUCH SOMEONE IN THEIR
FAMILY AT RISK. AND WHILE WE
HAVE MANY OTHER WORKERS WHO ARE
HAVE IN EFFECT NO CHOICE
ECONOMICALLY BUT TO GO TO WORK
C. WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND OTHERS.
MANY OF THEM ARE ALSO IN FEAR
EVERY DAY OF BRINGING THE VIRUS
HOME. BEYOND WHAT WE NEEDED TO
DO WAS STRIKE A BALANCE THAT
GOT OUR KIDS BACK INTO THE
CLASSROOM BUT ABSOLUTELY
MINIMIZE THAT RISK. BY BRINGING
THAT BUYERS HOME WEATHER HOME
TO THE CHURCH STUDENTS FAMILY
TO THE STAFF'S FAMILY OR TO THE
TEACHER'S FAMILY WHICH OF
COURSE WOULD EXACERBATES BACK
COMMUNITY SPREAD. AND MANY OF
US HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING GERMANY
AND- I HAVE BEEN IMPRESSED
WITH- THE- THE SCIENCE BASED
RESPONSE THAT THE GERMAN
GOVERNMENT AND DIFFERENT LEVELS
AT ALL THROUGH ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT HAVE HAD THE-
BASICALLY THE HIGHER AMOUNT OF
IT HERE IT'S SOCIALLY TO BE
MASK WEARING INTO OTHER
PROTOCOLS AND YET. GERMANY
ITSELF ONLY RE OPENED THEIR
SCHOOLS THIS WEEK. THEY ALSO
HAVE BEEN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
SPREAD AND SO I THINK THAT WE
NO ONE IN THEIR RIGHT MIND
WANTS TO GET CODE NINETEEN NO
ONE. AND I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED HERE. AND IT TOOK A
LONG TIME BECAUSE IT WAS.
DIFFICULT TO WORK OUT SOMETHING
THAT REALLY MET THE NEEDS OF
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS SO WITH
THAT LET ME CALL ON SENATOR
LAYERED I MOVE THE BILL. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION. SEEING THAT
DEBATE IS CONCLUDED. LET US
CALL THE RULE. AB EIGHTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATOR
SKINNER. BY SKINNER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I COPY AERO COPYRIGHT I
CORTESE CORTESE I DOLLY. KALIAN
BERADA. TORONTO II AIKMAN. A
MAN I GROWTH. GROW BY LAYERED.
LEHRER DIE MCGUIRE. THE GLARE
HI MELINDA WINDOWS I MELINDA'S
I MAN. MAN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN
NINE. THE TROUBLE. A TROUBLED I.
CAN CAN I ROCK. ROTH I STERN. I
STRYCHNINE STERN I Y. CASKEY.
LIKE I SAID MY COFFEE I. THERE
ARE NO ABSENT MEMBERS FIVE FIVE
EIGHTEEN NO ZERO. ALL RIGHT
SEEING A HAVING THE BILL PASSED
THE BILL IS OUT AND WITH THAT
THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
WILL CONCLUDE.